Welcome back.
My children.
My brothers and my sisters.
Wait, that would not make you my children.
Wait, are they brothers and sisters or are they children?
It's children.
No.
It's...
I'm the sister.
I have blood on my forehead.
It's from all that sweet, sweet exercising I've been doing.
Don't worry about it.
When you were brushing your teeth, did you miss?
I had spaghetti right before this.
I was like, oh my gosh.
You know when you have something and you're like, all I can taste is that thing?
I was like, okay, spaghetti is great and all, but I just don't want to taste any more spaghetti.
Can I get a...
Let's go, Dodgers!
It's the sauce.
It's the spaghetti sauce on my forehead.
Garlic bread.
Garlic bread!
Oh my gosh!
You reminded me I had a garlic bread and I forgot.
No!
I made garlic bread.
I forgot to have it.
Oh my gosh, it's still in the oven.
Oops.
It's off.
Don't worry.
It's probably not burnt, I think.
I think it's okay.
Look at your bread.
No, I don't want to eat it now.
I'm full.
I ate all the spaghetti.
She hates garlic bread?
No.
What am I, a vampire?
No, I'm a ghost.
I've been a zombie.
I'm a ghost.
I was an angel.
I'm ticking off all the supernatural creature boxes.
Did you hear the Vatican just revealed a cute anime girl mascot?
No way.
Actually?
Yes?
Hold on, I'm looking this up right now.
No way.
Four hours ago.
Wait, why are her... Wait, is this the right girl?
Oh!
Oh my god.
She's so cute!
Wait, Lucy?
Is that how you say it?
How do you say her name?
Luce.
Oh, Luce.
Which is it?
Luce.
Hold on.
Uh...
Into Italian.
Italiano.
What?
It says here that it's Italian for light.
I put in light into Google Translate and it does not give me that.
It gives me this.
Leggera.
Yahweh.
Oh, it's Latin?
Okay, well, this article is wrong.
Luce.
That's not right either.
Google Translate, what's wrong with you?
It's not Latin.
Wait.
I don't know what's correct anymore.
I don't know anything anymore.
Oh my gosh, it's so cute, the little character.
Oh my gosh.
Why though?
Okay, is this a YouTube video?
Hold on, I'm muting it just in case.
Why does she have like blood on her shoes?
Why does she have blood on her shoes though?
Hold on, let me screenshot it.
Look at that, she's got blood on her...
Don't mess with the Vatican.
What is thine favorite passage?
Mine is Ezekiel 2320.
It speaks to me personally.
What's that one?
Mayah!
Welcome to my bishop.
Thank you!
Oh, is it mud?
I don't know.
It's kind of terrifying.
Looks like a smile that would absolutely destroy you.
Why has she got mud on her shoes anyway?
The valley of death.
Hope you're feeling okay, Mayah.
I recently bought a 90's anime series on DVD and didn't realize until today that David Hader voice is the main guy.
Is it Fushigi Yugi?
Because if it is, I know.
You have blood on your forehead.
I know.
Sorry for getting you banned in Matara's chat, but it was really funny.
Road, it was you!
She's a shepherd, so she has mud on her boots.
I think they need to recolor it.
I think the brown... If it's brown...
I think against the green just makes it look very red.
Or is it just me?
Is it just me?
It looks red.
I think they need to...
It's kind of scary.
Oh, goodness.
How excited... I just want to say how excited all the wists are for 3.0.
Everyone is very, very hyped.
You deserve the shiny new Korone voice.
Have confidence.
Thank you!
Could be clay.
Possibly, yeah.
There's red clay.
As for how I'm feeling, yeah, I'm feeling so much better.
I'm not 100%.
But I think I'm good enough to stream at least.
At the very least.
I'm not in so much pain anymore.
Zen, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
So...
Pain be gone.
Basically, I had some sort of reaction on my face.
And like...
I basically...
Okay, this is gonna sound so horrible.
Sorry, I'm really embarrassed.
Talking about it.
Oh my gosh.
I basically...
I looked like the Joker in the Dark Knight for a couple days.
It was kind of horrible.
And so I couldn't move my mouth.
Without...
You know what I say?
I'm gonna become the Joker sometimes.
I actually did.
And I like...
It was just so bad.
I guess it was some kind of allergy.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
But it's nearly gone.
Luckily, it doesn't show up on camera.
So you guys can't tell.
It's all the makeup and stuff I'm wearing.
Joker cosplay this Halloween.
Honestly, if I had gone to a...
I could have gone to any haunted house.
And they would have hired...
I mean, they should hire me anyway.
I'm a ghost.
They would be like, whoa, scary ghost.
But then also...
Oh my gosh, they could have put me in Phasmophobia.
And I would have fit right in.
I'm the Joker, baby.
Yesterday.
I laugh about it now that I'm not in pain.
And that I'm feeling better.
But I was like...
Oh my gosh.
I was like just...
I was sobbing from all the...
From how much it hurt.
And then...
The tears would...
Touch my face.
And I would...
The saltiness would burn even more.
And I'm just like...
It was a rough couple of days.
But I'm better now.
Possessing Freddy Fazbear.
I don't...
Freddy Fazboar.
But I'm okay.
I'm so sorry I had to cancel streams.
I'm really sorry.
And I had to move some stuff around.
I had to...
Move DMC to tomorrow.
And...
Astrobot to Saturday.
Oh my gosh.
Being a ghost is just...
As bad as being alive, I think.
You can't win in life and you can't win in afterlife.
It's so messed up.
Moving your mouth is important too.
I know.
I couldn't speak.
And I couldn't eat either.
I couldn't open my mouth to eat a lot.
So I would just...
I got smoothies and stuff.
I forgot to tell you how great you did on the karaoke relay.
You were so much fun despite everything going on.
Thank you!
Last night I was...
Mostly feeling better to stream, I'll be honest.
But I wanted to give it a little bit extra time to...
Fully...
Calm down.
I think we're there.
Take care, big day coming up.
I know, I was so worried.
But I'm glad I could at least do the karaoke.
I had a lot of fun.
Even though...
Some people...
Didn't seem to appreciate...
Some of my songs.
You need to answer for that monster mash.
My right ear left out.
I don't know what happened.
I'm so angry.
If you guys don't know the context.
I did a karaoke relay.
That was a crime.
I'm gonna say something that's gonna probably piss you guys off even more.
You can thank TikTok.
I saw someone sing that version on TikTok.
And I was like...
But then, they didn't do the whole song.
So I was like...
I wonder if there's anything else.
And then I found a...
Another site that had like...
Finished lyrics.
So I...
I just kind of mashed them together.
So sorry, these heathens have no taste.
Monstua mash.
Hey chat, make sure to vote for Mint in the best vtuber in the streamer awards.
Because she's the very best.
Thank you, GoldenFoxy.
Actually, I voted for Doki.
Since she tweeted about it.
I don't really care about the...
Streamer type award.
Things like that.
Like vtuber awards or streamer awards.
Or anything like that.
You know, I really appreciate it.
But, you know.
That's not something I'm like...
Oh my gosh, I wanna win.
But if someone does wanna win, then I'll be like...
Okay, I'll put my vote to you.
Saw the Dragoon Rally called to vote.
Yeah, so...
I think...
I think she has a good chance.
You are my streamer of the year, Minto.
Wow, thank you.
If you think that...
That honestly is all that matters to me.
You know.
And if I do ever win something or like...
I'm nominated for anything like that.
Of course, I'm not gonna be like...
Ew, what the heck.
But...
You know, I would of course appreciate it.
You did not sing the...
Jedward version?
What's that?
Who's that?
Squidward?
Heard of Doobie?
Yeah.
I have.
Yeah, I watched her debut.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute.
She's so cute.
I love trains.
I was like...
Train conductor.
She Doobie making a name for...
Oh my gosh, it's like the perfect name ever.
Sometimes I'm like...
I wish I could change my name.
Because I feel like names that are two syllables are perfect.
You know?
That's why I'm really happy when people call me Minto.
They just end up being more catchy.
I was like...
Mint is good, but...
I wish I could change my name sometimes.
So thank you for calling me Minto.
Rolls off the tongue.
Yeah, exactly.
And Doobie is just such a good name.
Very fun to say too.
I feel like names that are two syllables are fun to say.
You know what I mean?
Minto, Minto, Minto.
Minto, Minto.
Bonion.
Three syllables in shambles.
No.
It's just my opinion.
Minto.
Minto is a really good name.
Yippee.
Onion.
Tony, Toto.
Tonto.
Tito.
Good thing I don't have a Y.
Toot.
Anyway.
I've been talking for long enough.
Welcome everybody back to Faith.
The Unholy Trinity.
Today we'll be playing...
Chapter...
I almost said Chapter 4.
Chapter 3.
And...
That's the last chapter.
Are they making any more?
I don't think so.
It's the Unholy Trinity.
No, they're not going to make any more.
Rain of bees?
Not bees.
A singular bee!
Oh my god!
Happy birthday!
Chapter 4 is in development?
But it's the Unholy Trinity.
Unholy Quadrinity.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, singular bee.
So yeah.
I think this chapter is a little bit longer.
If I remember correctly.
So let's get into it, bae.
Bae.
Oh, I like the different colors.
Yellow.
White.
Orange.
New game.
Show needles?
Oh no.
Sorry guys.
I'm really not good with needles.
So I'm sorry.
I will not show needles.
I'm really really bad with needles.
So...
Birthday song, Dax.
Are you saying it's your birthday?
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to yourself.
Never seen the censored version?
Well, let's see how it is today.
Grayscale.
September 21st, 1986.
I can't hear you.
Yeah, sure.
Based on what I saw during my previous visits.
We could be in for a very long night.
Is this your first exorcism?
Why are they in water?
Are you afraid?
I don't know, sir.
Yes, sir.
I'll give you a word of advice.
Follow my instructions with exactness.
Don't trust what you may see or hear.
Yes.
Oh, it's the house.
Oh my god.
I can also move.
Excuse me.
Oh my gosh.
Good evening, Mr. and Mrs. Martin.
This is my assistant, Father Ward.
That's me.
I'm part of this family now.
Shall we begin?
Hello, wife.
She's in the back.
I had to tie her up.
I understand.
I'm narrating it because...
It's hard to hear them.
The Lord's servants are here.
If you say so.
There I go.
I'm going before you guys.
What's that sound?
This is the attic?
I don't think I'm supposed to be here.
Oh gosh.
She orple.
Oh my god.
They did say that they tied her up, but when they went to go see her...
She was in the attic.
She was missing.
Why don't you lead the way?
This is my first ever exorcism.
Why don't you take me there?
Oh, but she's there!
Interesting.
Oh my god.
Hello, Amy?
Konichiwa?
Can you hear me, Amy?
I love the vibes of this game.
I know, right?
She's talking to me!
My nightmares.
October 28th, 1987.
Three days until the profane Sabbath.
And welcome to chapter three!
Oh my gosh.
That's so hard to read.
John.
We don't have much time.
The profane Sabbath is almost upon us.
If they find Nate and Jason, they will perform a ritual on them to call forth a demon of unspeakable power.
The name of the demon is Malthus.
I am in the process of discovering their whereabouts.
I will contact you again soon.
We must not let them do to the boys what they did to Amy.
Father Garcia.
If you...
It would be interesting if Father Garcia doesn't live.
And it kind of carried over into this game.
That save, if you had it, you know?
Wait, October 28th?
That's today!
Lilacs may bloom, but evergreen stays mint.
Through seasons change and warmth to gloom.
Forgive me for I am a simp.
No, I didn't!
Yeah, I'm not going in there.
No, I didn't plan that at all!
Don't say the demon's name.
It gives him power.
John.
I can't find Nate or Jason Martin in the state foster care system.
It's possible that after what happened last year they went to live with relatives.
I will try to find out what I can.
Meanwhile, go investigate the clinic where Amy worked.
Oh no!
How do you keep syncing with dates and games?
I don't know!
Wait, does that mean my 3.0 is on the profane Sabbath?
Crazy!
We must find the place where they intend to summon Malthus and disrupt their plans.
Vea con Dios, Father Garcia.
Wait, I don't want to leave yet.
Oh my god, my family photos!
Except my wife left me.
It's really sad.
What's downstairs?
Our basement is like way different.
Renovated even.
I think we need to watch out for this leaking problem though.
Our water bill is gonna be insane.
Oh my god.
There's gonna be so much mold!
I think these are just pillars.
Yeah, it's gonna get really moldy.
Wait, how is our basement so different from before though?
Alright, let's check out this note.
Stinky mold demon.
Nasty!
Get out of here, mold!
I'm the mold priest!
Oh my god, that would be a sick business.
You come in dressed as a priest, but you're really here to take care of the mold?
You've got a mold problem!
I don't know why it sounds like Mickey Mouse though.
I'm gonna walk there.
Hup hup hup hup!
Hello?
Neighbor?
Oh my god!
I think I vaguely remember this.
What are they watching?
Oh my god, they're watching anime.
Are you an otaku too?
Knock knock!
Hmm...
Is this the Rick rule?
No, it's not.
Is it actually?
Notorious PSG!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
Mold-sersis?
Come on, it's time to find the door to darkness.
Can I keep walking?
Na na na na na...
I recognize 2loveru anywhere.
That's concerning.
Is it really a Rick rule?
Oh, I think I see it.
Wait, this part I don't see though.
Never gonna give, never gonna give, give you up!
Alright, it.
Okay, don't stand in the middle of the road, priest.
What about the other side?
I'm the creepiest.
Everybody is just like, watch out for that priest in the neighborhood.
That guy is so weird.
He goes around and looks in your windows.
Oh my god!
This is the most popular show ever!
Everybody is watching it.
It must be...
Naruto!
Alright, let's go.
Leave?
Yes?
Bing bing bong...
Bing bing bing bong...
We are fighting a dream...
Does it say Amy and graffiti on the wall?
Hello?
Boy golly.
Oh my god!
I could have gotten run over just then.
Why did you park on the wrong side?
You turn around.
Oh my god.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running!
Y'all got any Jesus in your house?
Can I get run over actually?
Test it?
Police officer!
We got isekai'd.
Oh my gosh!
I should have known that that was...
Real.
I caught up on...
Re Zero yesterday.
Father Garcia told me to stop watching this scary vtuber ghost girl or a demon will take my soul.
Spicy!
I think I have to find another entrance.
Here we go.
Ko...
Wa...
Ran...
Beelzefest!
Ah yeah!
Calling all Metal fans!
Beelzefest 1987 rocks the hell out of Hartford.
Friday night 10pm to 2am.
Featuring appearances by...
When all is said and done.
Trust no corpse.
The horror is dead.
Basement 2.
What does that mean?
Everybody doesn't care about Basement 1.
Basement 2?
Tsk.
Return to bondage.
Among the bloodied.
Lying still in silence.
Mother of Shadow.
The door to Afterbirth.
The sequel to Basement...
Advance sale tickets.
$3.
Admission at door $5.
Yo!
So cheap.
Shadow the Hedgehog's mom.
Huh?
You feel watched.
So creepy.
Oh my goodness.
The music sounds very...
Just a little bit like the Exorcism music.
Facts!
To Rhonda Erickson from...
Gary Miller!
Hi Rhonda.
Just a couple of reminders after last week's visit.
Please keep your desk tidy.
Our patients need to feel at ease with their healthcare experience.
Remember our sales points.
Clean.
Quick.
Courteous.
Do not return any calls from the Department of Health before notifying me first or leaving a message with Tiffany.
We cannot afford another surprise inspection.
Oof.
Please do call me on my direct personnel line if you happen to hear back from Ms. Martin.
One more thing.
Keep Jeffrey out of sight.
Remember.
Gary loves you.
And facts.
Finally, somebody loves me.
Why'd the music stop?
Oh gosh.
It makes me so uneasy.
Note to self.
Pills do not dissolve in IV drip well.
Too weak.
Patients waking up before process is complete.
Sooner or later they will realize they are having the same hallucinations.
Suggest concentrated injectable version.
What is this?
Baby.
Snail?
Baby!
Oh my god, the baby scared me.
Yeah, I know.
Oh my god, that scared me so much.
I didn't even try to go up to it.
Oh, we can get our...
This chair looks haunted.
Ok, nevermind.
Oh, it's just in the...
It's the...what's it called?
Corner for bad children.
Oh guys, I'm so scared.
I'm scared.
It's so quiet.
I feel like I'm going to get chased in any second right now.
Baby, baby, baby jump scare.
I
think I died.
Oh my gosh, that scared the heck out of me.
This is one way to move.
Oh my god.
I need to hide.
I'm hiding?
Oh my god.
Ok, but the one in the top right kind of looks...
I don't know.
Is this loss?
No, it's not.
Oh, I see it!
It's...Oh my god, there's loss on the...
What's...
That's so messed up.
Not...No way!
He doesn't see me, right?
Oh, can I go now?
I think this is my chance.
Go.
Don't say I need to hide again though.
I'll be too scared.
I think if I...
Where?
Wait, where?
Oh my god, I'm going to die.
Where do I hide?
There's nowhere to hide!
Up the stairs!
Ok.
I think he noticed me.
I think maybe with the bodies...
Understandable.
Ok, let's hide.
I need to hide.
That rotoscope scene is a reference to an old horror movie that influenced the Silent Hill theme.
Jacob's Ladder.
Really?
I don't think I've ever seen it.
I've heard of it, but I've never seen it.
He's going to look at that guy.
He's just like...
He's going to look at this guy.
He's like...
He's going to look at the other guy.
Woo!
I think I'm moving, yeah.
Wiggle!
Wiggle, priest, wiggle!
Ok, wiggle.
Alright, I'm spamming down.
Spamming, spam, spam, spam, spam.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm trying!
Maybe like right in here.
Tetris.
Tetris, Tetris.
I'm amongst the bodies.
He's going to go upstairs.
Is he leaving?
Ok.
Priest, how are you going to get yourself out of this one, man?
Do I go through this door?
Bust it down.
Ok.
Up the stairs.
I guess.
Oh my god, the police!
I didn't do anything!
Jacob's ladder is extremely good.
Ok, let's leave then.
Wait, hold on.
Before we go, what's behind this door?
Police?
You're going to protect me, ok?
I guess nothing that we can tell.
What if I go back up?
I don't think he thinks I did this.
The door is later.
Oh, he's gone.
He was afraid of the police.
Probably because he's a criminal.
Criminal demon!
You're under arrest for being...
too hot.
Because you're from hell.
Ok.
The boss is...
Pure, pure, pure, pure, pure, pure!
I like how he sometimes just turns around.
He doesn't always have his gun out, just sometimes.
Ok, don't leave too far.
We're going up together.
Is there something in the window or am I crazy?
Baby...
I swear!
There was something here!
You're under arrest for being over the cute limit.
Sorry.
These baby jumpscares are freaking me out.
Officer, there is a thing here.
Officer, don't let me go ahead of you.
You are the one with the weapon.
Please, officer.
Don't draw it on me like that so fast.
Oh, we just got a save?
How did you get inside?
Ok, you can have it.
How did you know I had a crowbar?
Mortis...
I got you!
I think I'm dead.
Bye bye.
I thought he would die.
I thought I was stronger than that.
My faith is not strong enough, you guys.
My faith is not strong enough.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, when does he jump in?
I'm ready.
Ok, here he comes.
Other guy.
Shoot it!
Shoot him!
Oh my God, why are you running towards him?
What are you doing?
What about the crowbar?
Oh my God.
Run!
Freeze!
I mean cop!
Cop!
Run away!
Our faith is strong.
Oh my God.
Why don't you shoot it?
Oh good job.
A cop with one bullet.
For real.
Why didn't you shoot it?
Oh my God!
What's that?
Who was that driving by?
Do you think the door is open?
Wait, the windows are fixed.
Interesting.
The rat.
We gotta get the rat.
Little rat.
Is there anything else in here?
I'm scared.
Secrets?
Is there secrets in here?
Oh there is.
Is it the door?
Is it open now?
The one down here?
Oh my God, it's so scary.
Wait, it's not open I don't think.
Oh gosh, I can see their feet.
Wait, join...
It says join us at the bottom!
Oh my God.
Wow!
That didn't say that before.
Get in the bed.
Can I actually go there?
Is it a secret boss?
I think I saw someone say.
Oh gosh.
Yes?
Am I gonna be so sad?
Am I prepared for this?
I don't know.
I'm here!
I've joined you!
Hello?
Stay there.
Oh ok.
Stay still.
Oh gosh.
I can't look.
I think the preacher just likes it.
I think he just wants to...
I think he was just like this seems kinda neat.
Oh I don't like that.
Oh my God!
Maybe... Why did you strap yourself in?
Why did you do this?
I've never seen this before you guys.
Oh I thought it was a crane game for a second.
Osmosis.
Oh I saw his peepee.
Is that a baby?
Oh God.
At least it's saved.
Is it a boss baby?
I think so.
Boss baby be gone!
Oh she's got the baby.
I don't think she's the one to ask.
Gary.
You know who Gary is.
Oh my God!
That's the realest thing he's ever said.
Guys is this boss hard?
I'm scared.
Oh my God!
Little baby.
Oh no.
Oh no there's so many babies.
Oh my God.
Too many babies already.
Oh no, no, no.
Too many babies.
You can do this?
I'm scared.
It's the babies.
Ok,
good, good.
Baby.
Oh gosh, so many babies.
So many babies.
Oh my God, way too many babies.
Too many babies.
I went the wrong way.
Oh my God.
Oh shit, I'm gonna die by baby.
There's so many babies.
Oh God.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, there's too many babies.
Let them all congregate.
Congregate the babies.
And then take out the babies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ok.
I'm running away from the babies.
Ok, don't get too close to the walls.
Or the windows.
From the window to the wall.
Babies.
Babies inbound.
Oh my God.
Congregate the babies.
Oh gosh.
No, no, no.
I'm gonna die.
Death by baby.
Oh my God.
No, no, no.
Please.
There's too many babies you guys.
I'm not fast enough.
The babies are faster.
How are they so fast?
They are little crawling babies.
Oh my God.
Do you hear that?
Baby.
Baby sounds.
Oh stop.
Please.
How many babies?
Oh my God.
This is literally Metal Gear.
There's so many babies and they just don't stop coming.
Please.
Little babies.
Oh my God.
This is the Metal Gear Ray fight actually.
Go for the mom.
Wait, actually...
Is she the real horror?
No.
Hold on.
I'm getting baby.
I try to fight and I get baby.
Oh my God.
Yes, I have to get the mom.
Oh shit.
But there's too many babies.
You guys.
I'm surrounded by babies.
Oh my God.
They don't kill you yet?
They don't?
Oh, I see.
I see.
Oh my gosh.
There's too many babies.
What if I just did this?
Okay, hold on.
I'm letting them touch me a little bit.
Oh, they're crawling on me.
Oh, they're crawling on me real bad.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, this is not good.
I don't think this is good, you guys.
This is not good.
Now do they kill me?
Uh-oh.
Baby armor?
What are you talking about baby armor?
Do they kill me now?
Oh, I think they're weaker though.
Oh my God.
What the hell is that?
She's a lot... She's...
She's free.
She's got less baby.
Oh gosh.
The evil eye baby.
Okay.
Oh my God.
The baby armor is getting damaged.
There's just... There's fewer babies now than there used to be.
I think... Oh my God!
Wait, now are they going to kill me?
Ah, they're so loud.
These loud ass babies.
Uh-oh, they're making a new baby creature.
Okay, I killed it.
So many babies.
Oh my God.
Giant baby ghost.
Okay, I killed them both.
Get off of me babies.
Make me slow.
Okay, so they just make me really slow.
But as long as I can do this, it's fine.
I'm still exercising.
No!
Don't go to your mom!
Oh my God.
I can still get her though.
I'm getting the babies.
Oh the babies!
Oh, I think they're gone.
Did I do it?
This is what the pre-chat wisps sound like when you're late for stream.
Bottom right giant baby ghost.
Shut up.
We did it!
Oh, what's this?
Smooth moves, priest.
Get well soon.
Oh, thank you!
Thanks Jif.
Oh, sorry.
Thanks Nan.
Oh my gosh, Nan.
I thought about you yesterday because I was looking up...
The joysticks for the official Ace Combat joysticks.
I was just like... I was wondering if you had them.
Because I was thinking of getting...
Them for stream.
They have the Ace Combat 7 one and then the older one.
I can't remember what it's for.
Sean!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
But the twins are not here.
Carry out the works of your god while it is yet day.
For the night cometh.
Remember, Gary loves you.
Lmao!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Ding ding!
We did it!
We did it, guys!
Bing bing bong!
Bing bing bing bing bing bong!
So wait, so that guarantees us the true slash good end?
That little fight?
Oh, no.
Not yet.
Oh, okay.
It's part of the true end.
It's one part.
Okay.
One of three.
Okay, there's two more.
Just let me know when and I'll do it.
Because I want to see the true end also.
Thanks, lady!
For the five gifted!
I kind of want to buy them too, but I heard it's hard to do post all manure.
I hope it's not too expensive.
I was just looking at them.
I think...
I can't remember.
I didn't buy them yet.
But interesting that it makes it more difficult.
One per sub-chapter.
Ah, I see.
Was that Gary who went by?
What if you die by Gary?
That would be crazy.
Am I good to leave?
Yeah?
Okay.
There's a little more?
Check the cob.
Wait, where is he?
Over here?
Oh!
I didn't know this area was...
Oh my god, Uboa!
Oh my god.
We have nothing to say about that.
I don't think we should even be over here.
Villain, thanks for the super chat!
Person!
Oh my gosh, thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you!
Holy moly.
His gun?
I'm trying to take it, but it won't let me have his gun.
It's okay, I have my faith.
I keep reading the top as spaghetti.
Wait, there's even more.
Oh my god, it's the cool S.
A dog in the balls.
No, sorry, there's not a dog in the balls.
I'm just reading it.
That's what it said.
Oh, okay.
I think it just loop-de-doops.
I can't believe Uboa is up there.
And that our cop... Oh no, I'm so sad about him.
He protected us.
Is there anything else over here?
Airdorf.
Oh, okay, it's the same loop.
What is this about, dog?
Nothing.
Nothing at all.
Alright, I'm waiting for... Can I get the rat?
The rat has no faith.
I think there's something with the rat.
Is there actually?
Rat.
I can't get him though.
Oh, cross on here?
No, it doesn't work.
I think because it's an actual... thing.
Show yourself, thy rat!
Oh.
I can't tell if I'm getting...
I think I'm getting one guide.
Guys, I don't think there's anything with the rat.
You are.
That was close.
Alright, let's leave now.
Investigate the clinic.
Once you have time to play Ace Combat again, I will recommend you some video tutorials that will help you catch up to any Ace Combat for now.
I patiently wait.
Thank you.
Nico!
Welcome to Battleship Deku!
Was that because of the first boss?
Don't just stand there, fatherboard!
Get the book and recite the prayer of exorcism!
OK!
Exorcise-o-te-creature-a-salis...
Let me record.
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
Oh, there's more to it.
Adhurote serpens...
Shit, I'm not fast enough.
Sorry to get in the way of your...OK.
Exorcise-o-tabor-dium vivium phantasma!
Why are we leaving these books all over the place?
Clean up!
I can't read all that.
Just paragon like you never before.
Oh my god!
Mother, mother!
Get them out of here.
It will use the girl to afflict them.
Yeah, why are you guys in here?
Come on.
Come on guys.
Spooky, they moved!
Come on parents, what are you doing down here?
Parents, you're not allowed...this is...no.
This is an exorcism...you have to have your exorcism clothes on.
You don't...
You guys like chill in here.
It's best that you stay here.
That thing down there, that's not my daughter.
Synchron mixes.
I don't know what to tell you.
We need to go assist father Alren.
Stay here and pray for Amy.
Alright guys, exorcism.
I wiped off my feet.
What?
Oh.
They're back to normal.
Wait, is that how they were before?
Take it and save her?
Are you alive?
You died?
Don't worry Amy, I'm coming.
Wait!
Oh my god, he literally said it's dangerous to go alone.
Take this.
October 29th, 1987.
Two days until the profane Sabbath.
Good, it's not today anymore you guys.
It's today, maybe for you.
It's tomorrow for me.
Oh my goodness, we got a lot of mail.
John.
For now, this is the only way I can contact you.
I think they're watching me.
I need you to come over as soon as you can.
The situation has gotten much worse.
My address is 665 Orange Street, Apartment 5A, New Haven, Connecticut, 06511.
Thank you, Lisa.
P.S.
If for some reason I don't answer the door, get the spare key from my friend Tiffany.
Tiffany.
Like the one from the clinic?
Yeah, sorry I just doxed Lisa you guys.
It's for the plot.
We doxed for the plot, okay?
We have to.
Doxed.
I said it so cat.
I was like...
I didn't even think about it.
I didn't even think that I was saying some person's address.
I was just like, la la la.
Lisa's address.
I hope nobody goes there.
John.
There's an apartment building in New Haven where they might be attempting to summon...
I'm not able to go there myself.
It's up to you to stop their rituals.
Father Garcia.
I was on Koa's birthday stream today.
She did like a call-in thing.
And I joined.
She's from Idol ES.
And she said... Oh wait, I wonder if we can do this.
She said my Spanish sounded good.
Oh.
Sorry if I yawn a lot.
I had coffee earlier, but I had it like kind of midday.
And so it's like wearing off, but I don't want to drink more coffee.
I don't want to have so much caffeine, you know?
Be proud, Mint.
Ha ha ha.
John, I don't know if you're getting my letters or not, but I hope you'll be here soon.
I really need your help.
They're in the apartment.
I see them all the time now.
I can hear them in the darkness.
I haven't slept in days.
When you get here, just come straight to my place.
Tiffany can't be trusted.
Don't talk to my neighbors either.
They won't let me leave.
Lisa.
Oh my god!
Lisa!
Let's see how my neighbors are doing.
Are they still watching the same channel?
If so, they might be possessed.
Okay, they're good.
They're watching.
What the hell is this?
Oh.
This doesn't look very family friendly.
Darkwing, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Mint is a normal ghost being like you or me.
I don't know.
Your Spanish sounds good.
You said...
And now the babies are trying to eat you.
What's wrong?
I eat babies.
Alright, let's go.
I also eat babies.
There was a clean parking there.
Whose purple truck is this?
It's possessed, maybe.
Oh, can I walk down this street?
Thanos truck?
No?
Okay.
William Aftons?
Among the damned.
Gosh, the music in this is so freaky.
I say music, but ambiance?
So scary.
Who's just leaving their mail out?
Oh my god, Lisa!
Hello, Mr. Ward.
I am sorry to have worried you.
I am perfectly fine.
I have not been feeling like myself lately.
However, I am much better now.
Please do not trouble yourself with coming to visit.
I have decided to take an extended vacation in the country, so you...
In the country!
So you will not find me at home.
Sincerely, Lisa Pearson.
I shall take my other notes from Lisa.
Okay, see you, Lisa.
For the younger chatters, this is what the world actually looked like before Megaman invented HD reality.
It's true.
Bye, Lisa.
See ya.
Lisa?
Oh my gosh, I can actually leave!
That's crazy.
Wait, if I leave, do I get an ending or something?
Hot single cultist near you in New Haven.
What apartment is she?
Ping pong.
Lisa?
Wait, does this go upstairs?
5A.
Oh, thank you.
I think I remember vaguely...
A boss, something, in like a room.
Oh gosh.
Excuse me.
A sword.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
I'll take that.
Hi from Sapporo.
Oh my gosh, Seymour.
I've been seeing all your pictures.
If I had a nickel for every different location within Japan, I'd call it a faith livestream.
Okay, I'll just wait for that.
Are you going to be at Anime Atlanta by any chance or is it remote?
I believe... I mean for the concert.
I'll be there.
But it's not like a thing with the convention.
It's just happening at the same weekend as the convention.
And for those curious, it does not overlap with the Hololive concert.
So, you can get your fill of all the concerts.
Everything initiated... Oh sorry.
Every initiated follower knows that in order to bring about the second death...
One must sacrifice seven...
Seven...
Anuses.
Is that like a little star butt?
I wasn't planning on going to AWA until they announced the Hololive concert taking place the day after yours.
Yeah, yeah.
You know how like when there's like a little plushie of a character and they have a little star for their butt?
That's what I think about that.
By passing them through the star carved out of the impure...
Just think of that as a butt instead.
Of the impure vessel's face.
Oh god.
Then shall the unspeakable reward the butt with the second death.
Such was the fate of that whore, Amy.
Oh my gosh.
My beloved Gary has set his sights far too low.
I will surpass her.
Oh my gosh.
There's a secret...
There's a secret tunnel here.
I was hoping you see Dolphy Dream Mint Phantom.
Have you posted it?
I have not seen it yet.
Sometimes...
Oh this is up.
Hold on.
Oh yeah, I think I explored everything downstairs.
Sometimes, if you post things on like tags on Twitter, I don't always see them.
I need a color to describe you to my friends.
Whenever I say green woman, they think of someone else.
Is there a shade of green you are so I can narrow it down?
A preference of green.
Mint?
Mint green?
Wait, do I need to go into the elevator?
Isn't there something in here as well?
Actually, I'm just gonna take the stairs.
Who's smoking behind the bush?
Yo, this apartment complex is...
Oh gosh.
I think they have some troubles.
Can I turn this off?
Please?
I don't like it.
Oh god.
What is that?
Oh 5A!
I got it.
What is clevis?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's starting to...
Oh gosh, this game is so scary.
Why did it just save?
Hi, Amy.
Is that thunder?
Oh gosh.
This is the worst apartment complex ever.
Imagine having to go all the way down a hallway just to go up.
It's so obnoxious.
Oh my god.
Oh 5A.
I think this is the one.
What's this?
Well, what are the rules?
Wait, what's the rules?
Did I miss the rules?
No.
Oh my god.
I almost just quit the game.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean to.
I thought like exit the menu.
I haven't found the rules yet.
Maybe we gotta... Do I have to go all the way to the first floor?
Whoa.
They have a mold problem.
And I'm just the guy to fix it.
My nephew came into the room.
Do you have anything to say to him?
Hi.
Don't look.
It's a scary game.
And also, don't follow Timmy's examples because that kid can't spell.
Elevator friend.
1, 4, 2, 5.
6?
Oh, 6.
1, 4, 2, 6.
What's this?
There is no 7th floor.
Okay.
I believe you.
Is the elevator friend the other boss?
1, 4, 2, 6.
No, he's a friend.
So if I... Oh my gosh, do I have to go all the way back down to the first floor though to play it?
I actually don't know the rules either though.
No, what I mean is, is he the guy that I need for the true ending.
Okay, we go inside.
No, he's unrelated.
Oh, it's saved.
Oh boy.
Oh boy golly.
Lisa?
Lisa, are you in there?
What the heck is that?
Oh, the dagger.
What's that sound?
I got a key.
If you wish to break the seal of Alu, your answer lies in the bloodstained knife in the face hiding in the deep dark.
But only those who have ascended to the highest point can descend to the lowest depths.
Remember, Gary loves you.
Oh my gosh, the salt.
The salt's been disturbed.
And there's salt at the door even too.
I wouldn't be able to come in here.
You guys wouldn't do that though, right?
You guys wouldn't put salt in front of your door to stop me from coming in, right?
That would be so mean.
You guys are probably like, I mean, I want...
Oh, where did the candles come from?
I wasn't meant to haunt me.
All the time.
Stop with the salt!
What room was the dagger in?
I guess we'll find it.
Poor boy.
She's stinky.
Where are the candles?
Was it three, boy?
Three, boy.
Ah, nope, nope, nope.
No, it was not.
Mint is your sleep paralysis demon.
I put salt at the door so you can't leave.
That would be a salt.
You mean a waste of salt.
Totally.
It's this one.
The dagger is bloodied.
These guys are so fast and efficient.
I got it.
One seal.
Now we have to duel the guy in the darkness.
Whatever that means.
Why won't you let me... Just push!
Push, father, push!
He's just like, I'm so weak.
I can only hold up my little crucifix.
My arms are spaghetti.
Oh my goodness.
Is it telling me to go in the elevator?
But I'm not on the first floor.
I don't know the rules.
I don't know the rules with my buddy.
Mint is welcome, as long as she brings Omiyage.
Oh my gosh, this thunder is wild.
Oh, just the numbers?
I want to start on the first floor.
Or do you guys consider this the ground floor?
I didn't... I realized... Or did I look over here?
I realized to look in this one, but...
There's a basement.
Oh, I don't like this.
Uh...
Nope, nope.
No.
I don't have a flashlight, you guys.
That would be crazy to go down there.
Let's do our little friend... Wait, what was that?
Hold on, I gotta check my notes.
Scary picture.
One, four, two, six.
Okay.
One...
Four...
Two...
Six.
Wait a second, what do the numbers say?
Okay.
Friend!
Friend?
Spam floor seven.
Wait, it's eight, nine, ten!
Am I gonna die?
When's the last time I saved?
Oh, flashing lights!
Hello!
Oh, I'm playing.
One...
Let's check out eight, nine and ten.
Eight A.
Oh, what the hell is that?
What did it say?
Follow me tonight?
Oh, that's our friend!
Our sister Tiffany has gone against the will of the Unspeakable.
I thought I could trust her, but I was wrong.
Proceed with the original plan.
The woman in 5A will be our vessel.
Let her pious friend come to rescue her.
The Unspeakable shall crush them both.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Friend!
I don't know if he is a real friend.
I don't think so.
It's a scary game.
Scary!
Those who keep knocking on forbidden doors will be visited by the one who guards them.
What did that mean?
There is a seventh floor.
What?
That was so close.
Holy moly.
Does he die eventually?
Why?
Oh my god.
That was so close.
You guys, that was terrifying.
Is he in here too?
These are stairs.
You can't be in here.
Or else I'll get scared.
Where is he gonna come from?
Okay.
Taco!
Welcome to Mambu Ship.
Thank you!
In here?
Where are you?
Friend?
Friend!
Friend.
There is like this one haunted house...
at Fuji-Q Highlands.
It's like an hour... They say it's an hour long and they are not kidding.
It's an actual hour long haunted house.
Oh my gosh!
Pumpkin!
And you have to go...
Oh, haunted pumpkin.
You have to go up and down stairs and stuff.
When I went, I went with some friends and we were just like...
The staircase is the safe point because they can't scare you...
when you are going up or down the stairs because that's just dangerous.
So...
Really?
A full hour long?
Yes, actually!
It's very long.
It's very fun.
Williams Family Newsletter, October 1987.
If you are reading this, it means you have been invited to the Williams Family Annual Halloween Block Party!
It will be held on Halloween starting at 5PM in Apartment 9B.
Activities will start promptly, so please do not be late.
If you plan on bringing a plus one, please let me know in advance.
Only friends and family, aka those who received this newsletter, are invited.
Selective.
Also, just a reminder that this is a family friendly event, so please leave all overly scary costumes and masks at home.
Timmy is still traumatized after last year's incident.
We can tell.
Also, I respectfully ask that you keep alcohol and cigarettes out of the apartment.
Also, oh my goodness, we do not want a repeat of last year with the power going out, so please bring treats, but no tricks.
And just another friendly reminder that anti-religious or satanic imagery will not be allowed in the apartment.
Also, please be aware of Timmy's diet and food allergies.
And please be aware he suffers from asthma, so please do not sneak up on him or try to scare him.
Again, he still has trouble after what happened last year.
There's so much to this.
Oh my gosh.
You will also notice he has a new imaginary friend.
When you see him, please just roll with it.
Timmy's therapist says it's healthy for him to have such a coping mechanism.
God damn, Debbie!
See you all at the party!
Can't wait for you all to meet Mr. Miller, who has taken to Timmy so well and has become like a part of the family.
Debbie.
Is my friend not gonna show up?
Friend?
Not on the stairs, please.
Oh, these ones don't have numbers.
Master Miller.
I can't understand.
Follow me to... I can't understand what he's saying.
What is this?
M for Master Miller.
What's that sound?
Sacrifice what you claim to.
Oh my god!
Oh, why is it save?
Basement dumbwaiter.
How to use.
Pull up on handle to open hatch.
Place item or being to be sacrificed inside the container.
Pull down on handle to close hatch.
Press button to send dumbwaiter to basement.
Light will blink red if done successfully.
Please make sure your sacrifice does not jostle around inside the container.
Do I have to send my cross down?
No, no, no.
It says what I cling to.
I cling to my cross.
Do not open hatch once dumbwaiter has reached the basement.
I do not have enough earplugs and I am tired of people losing them.
Please wait for the green light to come on before using.
But how am I supposed to then kill my friend?
Oh my god.
Five Nights at Freddy's.
What do I do?
Kill him first.
Maybe I can.
Maybe.
He is really fast.
I don't think I will be able to outrun him.
We know he is...
Oh gosh.
Maybe I can just use the elevator and go all the way to the first floor.
Oh wait.
Hello?
Wait.
Oh my god.
That was so close.
I got him.
Oh my gosh.
Time to play elevator game.
Wait.
Oh no.
That's why I couldn't go inside.
2, 10, 5, 1.
Timmy?
Is that what I put in?
2, 10, 5, 1?
Save Lisa before doing this.
Wait.
Do what first?
What should I do first?
The elevator game or the...
Or the...
The cross thing.
Main first then elevator.
Ok.
I don't want to give up my prize.
I don't want to give it up.
Oh gosh.
Goodbye cross.
What did it say?
I have to wait until the green light, right?
What is that?
Why is it bloody?
Oh gosh.
Ok.
Hold on.
I'm reading the note.
What does it say again?
Do not open hatch.
How do I go?
I guess I go.
Oh gosh.
Party, party!
I don't have...
First floor I guess.
No, not the funky music.
Play that funky music elevator.
Oh no!
Who are you?
Oh shoot.
Oh you just gonna...
Gary lied to us.
When you see it, run.
Which way do I go?
Camera!
Oh my god, no.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna lose my marbles in here.
Too scary!
I hate segments like this man.
3B?
I think I go in here instead.
Oh gosh, I can't see in here at all.
I didn't see anything.
What is this?
Oh, over here.
Oh, I'm stuck by a wall.
I didn't see anything.
I died.
Think they were...
Think they were faster than I do, than I am.
Don't take photos there.
I learned that part.
Oh, it takes us right back to here though.
Ok.
I wish it recharged a little.
Those symbols were not there before I think.
Oh my gosh.
Oh gosh, run, run, run, run, run.
We were in the attic.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know where... Oh my god.
Was that a person down there?
I'm gonna die.
I'm about to die.
Oh, maybe not.
Ok, we are out.
I'm so sorry for anybody with flash issues.
Ok, I go into another room.
I love... Oh no, no, no, no.
Wait, I didn't see...
Wait, do I grab the dagger?
No?
Oh, probably the table.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ok.
We are going, we are going.
Oh gosh!
She is naked!
You guys, I'm trying to go...
Mother.
I'm going!
Oh my god, where is she going?
No!
This is evil!
Oh my god, I went too far.
Shoot.
I can't see anything.
Oh, this way.
Butter.
Alright, down the stairs.
Oh my gosh, I'm bleeding, why?
Or I stepped in blood?
Ok, keep going.
Gosh, this is a really long segment.
For like this kind of... What's the word?
Oh no!
For this type of...
Thing you have to do, you know.
Yeah, gimmick, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mechanic, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a very long section.
Ok.
I didn't remember how long it was before.
Oh my god, oh my god!
Oh, it saved!
Oh, thank goodness.
What is this?
Why couldn't I see with all these candles lit, huh?
Oh my goodness.
Why was my cross all the way over there anyway?
Go right?
Right here?
Fake candles.
Oh, I can go to the right.
What happens if we sprinkle salt on you?
It's like a snail, you know.
Hold on, let me get the note first.
Oh wait, what is this?
Hold on, let's get this first.
The seal!
Ok, saved.
Very good.
My beloved Gary.
Alas, the mask is already stained with blood.
My blood.
The ritual is complete.
You will not find me on this mortal plane, for I am beyond!
Look for me in the unseen world if you dare.
Tiffany.
Tiffany is... Tiffany is...
She just kind of took her own route with this, huh?
She was like, Tiffany, you're a little freaky.
Not seven.
Wait, what does that mean?
Seventy times seven.
Seventy times seven?
490.
Oh, Sister Minto, I must confess a most grievous sin.
I hath been watching other girls by the name of Maid Lilac and Maid Turquoise.
Can I be saved?
You are very brave for admitting that.
Oh god.
I know your secret.
Where are you?
Can I still get you Arthur?
You can't hide anymore.
Betrayer!
Thanks for the five guten!
Oh my gosh.
You sneaky.
Thank you so much for the five guten!
You belong to her.
Uh oh, leaky.
I can fix it.
I am the fix it priest.
I can fix anything.
Harbing Mint.
You belong to me.
You belong...
To me!
Oh, I didn't mean to skip that.
Hopefully I didn't.
Wood.
Oh my god.
I'm a little zombie man.
Don't fall down the stairs.
Be careful.
Oh my god.
I think I'm possessed.
Oh, I'm saved.
And I saved the game.
I should leave.
We gotta save Lisa.
What floor was she on again?
The door?
Oh, five, right?
Oops.
Well, we save Lisa and then we do the elevator, right?
What happened to...
This happened to my buddy Dave the other day.
Is Dave okay?
Try to save Lisa for the best ending.
Okay.
I can go downstairs.
Downstairs is this way.
You're tearing me apart, Lisa.
Oh, just kidding.
Other way.
Probably would have been faster to take the elevator.
You're tearing me... You know what?
I'm here.
Let's just take the elevator.
I've gotten enough exercise.
These demons have made me work for it for real, you know?
They have made me work for it.
Do you dislike elevators?
I've gotten stuck in an elevator before.
Have you not?
I still remember the longest I got stuck in one, though.
Oh no, it's open.
It's open.
If you fail to save Lisa, just click quit to the menu and try again.
Okay.
Kept you waiting, huh?
I really didn't, actually.
I took quite a...
I took quite a few detours.
Oh god.
Lisa!
Lisa, no!
I'm not Lisa.
Lisa!
I don't want to hurt you, Lisa.
Look at her go.
See that girl?
Watch that queen!
Digging the dancing queen!
Queen!
I think I got him.
Oh my god.
He's back in Lisa.
See that girl?
Watch that queen.
Digging the dancing queen!
Oh my goodness.
Which one is it?
You?
Oh my god.
I can save you, Lisa!
Oh my gosh.
I don't know if I'm doing this correctly.
Hold on, Lisa.
Get away from me.
Luckily she's a little slow.
Lisa also takes the elevator.
Oh my goodness.
Is it?
You're doing it right?
Okay, cool.
Thank you.
She's really going now.
It's so funny watching her.
Oh, I've been...
Fight it, John!
Restart.
That's so scary though!
I was doing so well!
I can't believe I got so lucky on the first couple ones.
Can she touch me?
No,
I actually...
I was just guessing.
I was just guessing for all of them.
I didn't know that he was going into a specific one.
To be honest.
Oh goodness, Lisa.
Okay.
She's got that spicy touch.
There's a way to tell?
Wait, how is it?
How do you tell?
Oh my goodness!
Watch the eyes.
I'm sorry guys.
I'm sorry.
When I get possessed, I guess I have... I tried pressing space, but I guess that didn't work.
Unless I didn't do it enough.
Begin.
Lisa.
Okay, so the eyes.
Okay.
Good to know.
The way he sounds is so disingenuous.
Lisa.
I'm so sorry.
I can't believe I got so lucky.
Wait, these don't have eyes.
Oh shoot.
Oh, hold space.
I'm fighting it!
Okay.
The demon's eyes, not the little mothman's eyes.
I thought they grew eyes.
Oh goodness.
It's okay.
Dang, I got so far and then...
Oh, I think it's the top one.
What?
I'm not very good at this.
I wish I hadn't died the first round.
Because I did so well.
Oh, this one.
How did I get so lucky before?
I think I'm a secret genius.
Oh, I couldn't tell.
I couldn't tell!
Oh gosh, this one?
No, this one?
Oh shoot!
I'm sick of this.
Oh no, Lisa.
I'm not Lisa!
Shut up!
The devil made me do it.
Okay.
Oh, that one was obvious.
Oh my goodness!
Okay.
He was getting awfully close to me.
Alright Lisa, we'll save you.
We'll save you.
Okay.
Top one?
No, bottom right?
When it splits one of them goes faster.
I see.
I can't get over how much is really just going crazy.
The bottom right.
Oh my goodness.
I didn't give enough space.
Uh-oh.
What the...what?
This is so unfair!
I'd rather her kill me than me killing her and then having to start all over and go to the main menu and everything.
This one.
Okay.
Back into there.
Oh my God!
Don't get close to me Lisa!
Lisa!
Stay away from me!
Stay away from me Lisa!
Lisa!
I'm not Lisa!
Oh shoot!
I don't know.
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
This one?
No!
Shoot!
I don't know.
No!
Man,
this is so frustrating!
Did you hit the wrong button?
No, I was holding down space!
I was!
He didn't fight at all!
This guy is so weak!
John sucks!
John Faith, I hate you!
You got to mash it.
I'm tearing you apart Lisa.
And then sometimes I can't tell which guy goes the fastest or whatever, whatever.
Goodness.
I think he's in the top.
No!
Come on!
I'm button mashing!
It's not working!
Oh my God.
We're going to be here forever you guys.
We're going to be here forever.
Shut up please!
I don't want to hear it anymore!
I don't want to hear it anymore Lisa!
You're tearing me apart Lisa!
Oh my gosh, get her.
Thank you for the five gifted.
I see it.
Oh my God.
Hold on, I got to get a good distance away from her.
If I can.
Oh my goodness.
Alright, Lisa!
Lisa!
Was it the bottom left?
He's getting faster.
Lisa, stay away from me!
Oh, she's good.
John's crucifix changes from gold to silver to bronze to symbolize his declining faith during the chapters.
You did great, I have faith in you.
Thanks villain!
No, that is not Lisa.
Lisa!
Oh my gosh, she's hot!
Thanks John, I'm not like how you told me off.
Listen, John, the bad man, Gary Miller.
Gary Miller?
Nor the granny.
Do you need a place to stay?
I'll be fine.
You can go in.
I don't think you will.
Your door is...
You have blood everywhere.
Oh my gosh.
We tried to have Riz and she rejected us.
Smooth one, John.
You want to come to my place, Lisa?
I sense another demonic seal was broken somewhere beyond.
Wait!
Is that the one that...
Is that the one that we're working on?
1, 4, 2, 6... Wait.
Hold on, I need to look at the notes.
Ok.
Alright guys, let's remember.
It's...
This one first.
1, 4, 2, 6...
2...
10, 5, 1... I can't remember.
Hold on, let me write it down.
1, 4, 2, 6...
2, 10, 5, 1...
Ok, I wrote it down.
I wrote it down, I wrote it down.
1...
This is going to take forever.
Ignore the granny.
Who's the granny?
Stop putting random numbers in the chat!
Memoirai.
4...
I mostly write it so that people who write the wrong thing can't confuse me.
2...
The granny insta-kills you.
Wait, what are you guys talking about?
6...
I need scissors.
61.
6...
It's based on Korean urban legend.
It said that an old lady might get on with you on the first floor and that you should not acknowledge it.
2...
The Riz wouldn't work because Lisa is his sister.
What?
We're in Connecticut, not Alabama.
10.
Oh my gosh, from 2 to 10?
That is removed lore.
5...
1...
Do I just stand here?
Wait, no.
No, I want to get out of this.
Wait, we're on 10.
How do we get to 10?
10...
Wait, I'm confused.
Wait, I thought we were on 1.
No, how did I mess up?
How did I mess up?
I tried to walk out, but literally I was too close to this and it triggered it.
And then you can't... I didn't see what floor I was on.
That's why...
That's why... Okay, I'll try it again.
I'll try it again.
Sorry.
2...
Sorry, guys.
2... 6...
6...
I do want to see it, though.
Just gotta...
6...
2...
No, not 7.
5.
MacCabbage, you're wrong!
MacCabbage, it's... I mean, it's not 5!
No, it's 7!
10...
5 and then 1.
I have ketchup.
Not on my forehead.
That'd be silly.
It's 7.
You said it.
No, I didn't!
It's 10... 5...
And then the lady will show up here, right?
Or does she show up at 1?
1...
She shows up here.
Okay.
So now I go to...
1.
Definitely 1.
Did I accidentally press 10 before?
I think you hit 1.
See?
I hit 1!
But it went...
Yes I did!
Oh, she said where are you going.
I'm leaving grandma.
Do I just have to ignore her?
Timmy!
Oh my god, Timmy.
Timmy and his friend.
But I killed the friend.
Timmy?
Are they in here?
Oh my gosh, it just saved.
Actually, good.
Timmy?
Timmy!
Hot!
Damn!
Oh my gosh, I love a dolly hand.
Finally!
For me?
Oh my gosh!
Tiffany.
How do you not know who Gary is yet?
She's threatening me with a good time.
Get you a girl like Tiffany.
Now?
Oh shoot!
Oh my god.
How big is this room?
Oh, it's actually quite massive.
I don't think I can get touched by those.
I wouldn't let you go, girl.
Oh my gosh.
Thank goodness you moved away from me.
Another silent hill call out boss there.
Oh my gosh.
I think we are OK.
Nice.
Are you gonna start working?
Why is the cross so weak?
Cross only works within certain inches.
Oh my god.
Please get away from me.
Yeah, thank you.
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
If I can just get a little bit in, please.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die.
Oh my gosh.
So close.
I know, right?
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
Please.
Stop moving around so much, Tiffany.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die.
The movement was unpredictable.
Dang, that was so close.
DVD screensaver of demons.
OK.
Yeah, yeah.
We get it, Tiffany.
You're high, OK?
Quit showing off.
Oh my god.
Can I please get a hit in?
So I think it's if Tiffany touches me, not the...
Oh my god.
Not the little spaghetti arms.
Oh my gosh.
Tiffany.
Tiffany!
Tiffany, Minto loves you.
No, no, no, no.
Oh my god.
I was facing the wrong direction.
OK.
Oh my god.
Run, run, run.
She's tough.
She's a toughie.
She's a baddie.
She's a badbie.
I mean she literally like beheaded herself for a man.
Tiffany, for a man?
Tiffany, have higher standards.
Carrie loves everybody, I guess.
Tiffany, love yourself more.
Tiffany.
Oh my god.
This is such a... This is the battle.
This is the...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, I can't even get a hit in.
Oh my god.
What?
No!
We were so close.
Hold on, I was drinking my tea.
I was drinking my tea.
I didn't... I thought it was like literally if like Tiffany's body...
Got me, you know.
Not his little scrangly self.
But the hitbox is a little weird, I think.
Oh my god, please.
No!
Because his body is also... So it's like really tall.
The top of her head got your foot.
Oh my gosh.
It's a bit bigger.
Yeah, it's a bit bigger than just Tiffany, unfortunately.
I have to watch for like the middle of the scrangle man.
That guy is dangerous.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, please.
Please Tiffany.
Oh my god.
Ok.
Tiffany.
I don't like this boss.
It's hard.
I'm not fast enough.
I'm not fast enough for Tiffany.
The music is kind of awesome though.
The music is awesome though.
Holy moly.
She is so hard.
Oh my god.
No, no, no!
Holy shit.
Just gotta get in a little bit.
Little bit.
If I can.
Oh my god.
I don't like this boss.
She is so tough.
She is so unpredictable.
I don't... I like girls.
Please.
Tiffany.
Tiffany, you're not my type.
I need a little more structure in my afterlife.
Ok?
Please.
She didn't like hearing that.
Take that Tiffany!
Thank you.
I didn't even flinch that much.
Well done priest.
You wasted another day aiding a worthless soul and you got rid of Tiffany for me.
Are you sure you know who's side you're on?
We'll find out soon enough.
Remember, Gary loves you.
She lets out 490 souls during the fight when she bounces around.
Divided by 7.
Have we done everything?
Can I leave?
Bum bum bum.
Timmy.
Oh, Timmy.
Oh my god, find Timmy.
Wait.
Did it just loop me?
Why am I looping?
Whoa, what's happening?
Go on the elevator?
Damnatio memory.
Huh?
I'm just gonna keep on going.
Oh, we're still in...
Why did it save again?
Seventh floor.
We made it, finally.
Oh, is this where Timmy's at?
Timmy!
You look like...
You look like you need some help there, Timmy.
Oh no!
No, Timmy.
He promised me so much.
I just want to see my little boy again.
The replacement is almost fully formed.
Just a few more bodies.
I don't think Timmy's been around for a minute, you guys.
I think Timmy has been gone.
I'm not gonna stick around to be one of the bodies.
Wait, do you think the elevator friend was Timmy?
Oh no!
Do you think maybe...
Do you think it was him?
That was elevator friend.
Okay, my bad.
Nah, that's a demon.
Poor Timmy.
Okay, well...
I thought like maybe his imaginary friend manifested to become him, you know what I mean?
Alright.
Time to go home, I think.
I think it's time to leave.
Investigate the apartments.
Good job, Minto.
Thank you!
Okay, we just have one more!
We just have one more!
Take it and save her.
Oh my gosh.
Father, I don't remember your name.
Father...
Who the hell is that?
Excuse me?
Spooky?
Freaky!
Who are you?
In the corner.
I don't like her.
Mr. and Mrs. Martin!
What's that?
What was blinking?
Amy Martin.
It's the church.
Oh, it's the thunder, okay.
Or the lightning, I mean.
Any spooky ladies?
What's this?
Glasses.
Bob's glasses.
Stay back!
In the mirror it's gold though.
Okay, we gotta go upstairs, right?
Stay back!
I see her!
Hey, lady!
Is she in every room?
Not there.
How's the family photo?
Yeah, let's check it out.
I don't see her in this room either.
Or this room.
I always think the thing up here looks like a little ball with a face though.
How's our family photo?
Oh no!
That doesn't look very good.
I don't see a spooky lady in here.
Hello!
I don't remember anything further.
Oh, we didn't go in there.
What about into the toilet?
Any spooky ladies in the bathroom?
No?
The bedroom?
Amy, are you in here?
Okay, so why don't we go into the kids room?
Amy, are you okay?
Are you okay, Amy?
Are you okay?
Watch out, Minto!
Where?
I don't see a spooky lady.
Okay, up to the attic we go.
There she is!
Head outside and try to leave.
I guess I could.
What if I do?
What if I do try to leave?
What if I'm like, you know what?
Amy...Oh!
Spooky lady.
Oh my gosh!
I've never seen that before.
That's so awesome!
Wow!
I've never seen that!
He's like, I must finish what I started.
Sadako.
Very Sadako-like, yes.
What is that lady?
Hello!
I'm here to save you.
You're here at last, priest.
Why are we going back to the basement?
Possum!
It's so quiet.
Sorry, you need to get better.
What about Meredith?
Did she get better?
Who is Meredith?
You couldn't save her, could you?
Ah!
Yeah!
Airdorf really cooked with this episode.
Right?
My little stick!
OK!
What do you mean Father Allred?
That guy is dead.
Oh my gosh!
More like Father Alldead.
October 30th, 1987.
One day until the profane Sabbath.
Spy on the neighbors.
Oh I do every time.
I'm what they call the peeping priest.
I look in through all the windows.
They're just like he's there again.
Put on his shows.
LOL
May I call you Father Garcia?
OK What's my neighbors up to?
Vaya con Dios.
I'm here!
Oh no!
Are you just watching horror movies guys?
Thank you!
Sorry!
Oh!
Gary loves you!
Bird!
This is like a sick music video.
LOL
Harvey thanks for the 10 gift card!
Oh!
What the heck is that?
Loves you Gary!
Loves
you!
Gary loves you!
LOL
Sick channel!
Oh!
Thanks for the gifts you guys!
Thank you!
Sorry I was too into my music video.
Sirstreak!
Alvin!
Ducky!
Thank you guys!
Let's go!
Leave ya!
Ah!
Which mix was that?
It was the Gary mix.
Oh my gosh!
Police officer!
You almost ran me over!
Holy moly!
Oh!
There is a standoff?
I think I'm at the wrong place.
Oh!
Ok!
I'm at the right place.
What if I go to the other side of the street?
Oh!
No!
Ok!
Yeah!
They can handle it.
Excuse me!
Oh!
Just a second.
I'm a priest.
You shouldn't let me in.
Excuse me!
I'm just walking in the middle of this active road.
I'm just like...
Excuse me!
What's going on?
Hello officer!
I'm going to speak in through the back.
Excuse me!
Can anybody tell me what's going on here?
Ok bye!
No one will ever notice.
Oh!
Even the bad guy, whoever they are trying to get, could just sneak out through the back.
They are so preoccupied with the front.
The guy is probably already gone.
I'm so sneaky.
A riddle priest.
How do you make a portal to hell?
Come see me and I'll show you.
The tunnels... Wait!
The tunnels await, but I wanted to check... Hold on.
I didn't get to go down.
Hey guys!
I'm not the killer.
Don't mind me.
I'm just a priest.
Wait, are these the tunnels?
I'll crawl through them.
Save and go see the police.
Wait, how do I go see the police?
Ben!
Ben has... Ben likes throwing people into the air.
What's this?
Hangman?
Oh, just leave through the front door?
Ok.
It's just save so I'll just... Oh Gary loves you.
Front door.
I'm on my way.
I'll go check it out.
Then we'll explore a little bit through here.
Welcome children!
Here we go!
Oh my god!
That was like the craziest bullet hell ever.
They were hitting the other guys.
A, B, C, D, E, F, G...
H, I, J, K, L Gary loves you.
Gary loves us.
Mother moon watcheth her little ones behind a door of sleep.
Daughter chalice is filled.
An offering to the Master in the unseen world.
Spirit bird arriveth from afar and cometh back to roost.
These vessels are the unholy trinity.
The fallen star shall guide them.
What colors can you see?
Look to the children if you are lost.
I don't know what any of that means.
Oh, there's the chalice and the star and the bird.
Okay.
Hold on, there's other pictures though.
Oh, there's little bugs in the flowers.
That's where they belong.
Not in my maid cafe.
Mason, age six.
I don't like that.
He's eating the mushrooms, just like in Mario.
Kaylee likes cats and she's crying about... Oh, even the cat is crying!
My dream!
No!
Kaylee, that's not a dream, that's a nightmare!
Kaylee, no!
Tyler, age seven.
Uncle Earl.
She has blastless phobia.
What about this one?
Max, age five.
Okay, these children are so cursed.
I didn't mean to say children.
Our family!
The cat is so cute though!
A... A... A... Amar?
Just Blair Witch Project, you know?
Whoa, Arcee!
Yeah, he's normal!
Omar, oh...
And then Sarah.
Oh, Sarah, age four.
Sarah has such an imagination, such a way with...
She's real... She just really likes... What the hell is that?
She really likes...
Thanks, Satin!
Oh, Ultra Kill!
It's the Ultra Kill guy.
Yay, Satin!
Satin gives us money, baby.
What is that thing in the other room, though?
A little bit of concern.
Cash money, baby!
Satin makes you a millionaire!
L, age four.
Ew!
Oh!
That's not in the other room.
Interesting.
Okay.
It's Satin.
All right, so we go on in.
What was the note about again?
Hold on.
Is this a Petscop reference?
I don't know.
I hate that I have to scroll all the way through.
It's kind of annoying.
Oh, I missed a couple notes!
Oh, no!
Oh, no, I missed a couple.
No, that's so sad.
Uh, okay.
The daughter chalice is filled.
Spirit bird.
Chalice bird.
Oh, wait.
Oh, moon, chalice, bird.
Moon, chalice, bird.
And then it leads to the star.
Pretty sure one of the walls in the candy tunnel in part two said hail satin.
It did!
Are the children writing the... Who was teaching them how to spell?
Wait, I thought this was a hole.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, oops, I messed up, you guys.
Moon.
Chalice.
Bird.
Star.
They changed colors.
Do I have to make the color correct?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, hold on.
Moon watcheth behind a door of sleep.
Chalice is filled.
What if they were all pink?
Pink.
Uh, read the last line.
Oh, oh.
Um, yeah.
What colors can you see?
Look to the children.
Oh, the drawings.
Wait, the bird was green.
I remember that.
It was like that, but I'll...
Okay, okay.
What was this one?
Was it anything?
Red star.
Okay, we got that.
Oh.
Red star.
Um.
Nothing.
Uh, orange moon.
Orange moon.
Does the... Do the colors stay?
No, they don't.
Okay, star red.
Moon orange.
Okay, we'll come back.
We'll come back.
Nothing.
Pink chalice.
My dumb ass is like, what if I made them all pink?
I'm double checking the birds since I'm here.
Oh, it was a blue bird.
Blue bird.
That one was green.
Oh, the money was green.
I was thinking of the green money thanks to satin.
Twitter.
Okay, bird.
It's a dark blue, that one.
Okay, star is red.
Chalice is pink.
Pink, pink, pink.
And the moon is orange.
There we go.
Yay!
This is where it lives.
Um.
Okay.
Oh boy.
Oh, this part.
What does that mean?
Oh gosh.
Oh my god, no.
Oh.
If you are reading this, then congratulations!
You are on your way to experiencing the wonders of our unspeakable future under the guidance of Gary.
Gary, our brother.
Gary, our friend.
Gary, a normal human being, just like you and me.
The more they say it, the less convincing it becomes.
As a tier one acolyte, you are just beginning your unspeakable journey to eventually see what Gary sees and prove yourself worthy to be a vessel fit to experience the second death reserved for only the most worthy.
Tiffany?
That girl was not worthy.
To find out if you are a vessel, remember to attend meetings of the eternal order of the second death twice a week.
Come to the group meetings.
Follow Gary's instructions.
Oh my god, exactly.
Be honest with him in all that you do.
Do not ever ask what has been behind the door in the basement of the clinic.
The one we went to.
A normal wisp, just like you and me.
With all the babies.
Sorry if I'm making you yawn too, guys.
I'm just a little sleepy.
She consumed six little twigs.
Only two were left to walk as husks.
Go ahead, priest.
Stare into the eyes of my mother.
I'm mommy?
Oh, what beautiful eyes you have.
Uh, okay.
Oh, I can't get around her?
I just have to keep looking at her?
Um, looks very Mona Lisa-esque.
Oh!
Um, Mona Lisa, five days on vtubers.
Two weeks on vtubers.
Oh, I'm still staring.
Oh gosh, three months on vtubers.
Oh, one year on vtubers.
Yeah,
I guess it's time to go.
Gosh, this guy loves walking through tunnels, I swear.
What's up with these cultists in tunnels?
I don't understand.
Gaze upon the magnificence of La Pieta Corotta.
This beautiful statue depicts a faithful member of the order receiving the second death in the loving embrace of Et Mater.
Two such statues were commissioned thanks to the generous patronage of the Save Family.
Sorry, it's really funny.
You never think about how cult people get their things, like their little statues, but they're talking like such vtubers.
They're like, we commissioned this artwork.
Just, just, just, just like a normal vtuber.
Um, we invite everyone to reverently approach the statue whenever they are in need of rest.
So is this a save point?
If you are reading this, congratulations!
You have officially been granted tier two status in the eternal order of the second death.
Oh my gosh.
So like, oh my gosh, what if this is like a sorority?
Upon crossing the threshold from tier one to tier two, your life as an acolyte will change dramatically.
You may start noticing shadowy figures in the corner of rooms or experience feelings of lost time when holding sharp objects.
Ancient symbols written in blood will materialize on the floor and walls of your home.
Animals will no longer trust you.
You may emit a foul odor that will cause your former loved ones to avoid you.
These are just a few of the marvelous blessings that await you in this new stage of life.
If you remain loyal to Gary, your journey towards becoming a vessel for the second death will progress to new levels of knowledge and power.
Oh my god.
Remember, if you neglect your weekly meetings or do not pay your pay your dues to the order, your fingers will be forcibly bent backwards.
Gary loves you.
Oh my god.
Uh, sneaking mission, I think?
Maybe?
Anyway, uh, I'm just a priest.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Toxic what?
What?
Toxic dog breath?
What are you saying to me?
Gary loves you.
I know.
Nekozuki, welcome to membership!
Oh, the second death.
Toxic dog breath.
I can't suck it.
Not here.
Toxic dog breath.
Wait, was there?
Hold on.
Oh, my bad.
Sorry to go through all my notes.
Gosh, I wish there was an easier way to go through the notes.
Uh, there were only two left to walk as husks.
Oh, stare into my eyes.
Pond crossing.
Oh, wait.
Is it the statues?
No.
Minto loves you.
Is Minto getting the true ending?
I'm trying.
There you are, you toxic dog death.
Toxic dog breath.
Toxic dog.
Oh.
Andres soweth discord.
East and west trade places.
Ghost priest going up against cultists and exercising demons.
Indeed a work of hearsay.
What do you mean?
Or dog stirreth his pot full of sinners.
The seats revolve.
Oh gosh, you guys.
I don't know how to play checkers.
Toxic dog breath.
Bale giveth favor.
The low seats are made high.
Five seats in the north facing west.
Five in the south face.
Bales.
Solve it for real this time, Mint.
You can get it.
What am I supposed to do, though?
Okay, hold on.
Let me go up and see.
Oh.
Uh, okay, hold on.
It's connected?
Toxic dog breath.
Okay.
Oh.
What?
Five seats in the north facing west.
Five seats in the south facing... oh gosh, this is...
My brain is too small for this, you guys.
Endress soweth discord.
East and west trade places.
Or dog stirreth his pot full of sinners.
The seats revolve.
I don't even know what I'm trying to create, though.
Bale giveth favor.
The low seats are made high.
Huh?
Okay, I'm just gonna go talk to somebody.
Let's talk to the owl.
Mr. Owl.
Um, what do I do?
He is...
Did any change happen?
Actually can't tell.
Huh?
What happened?
What changed?
Did they change?
Change places!
The run killer.
Okay, let's talk to the chef.
Chef, what have you say?
Oh, they moved again.
Who would have thunk that would happen?
So, uh, there was one guy here.
Oh, I think they flipped, right?
This is the one that said... hold on, he... so the chef is, uh, is Bale.
Right?
What do you mean almost?
And then the owl...
I think... I don't know.
I don't know.
You got this, we won't backseat.
I don't even know what I'm supposed to do though.
All right, let's try the old man.
What?
I don't know.
Oh, I think I did it.
Oh no, that's ambiance.
Um... or I did something correct.
Okay, uh...
But, like, five seats in the north... five facing... okay, so this is what I'm... okay, five seats in the north...
...west.
One, two, three... oh, okay, okay.
Oh, I just need this one.
It's a face... faith... faith...
Sorry, face west.
Oh, but all of them are... these ones are correct.
The five facing east.
No!
Um...
Uh, we don't want that one.
So, uh... the seats revolve.
The low seats are made high.
Does that mean they all switch?
Like it goes... like it does like a flipperoo?
How do I turn you over?
Just use your hands, priest.
Oh, sorry, I remember he's got them spaghetti arms, you guys.
So do I...
I mixed up east and west.
Oh, weest.
Yeah.
So, okay, we gotta... hold on, which one was Andrus?
Um... was it you?
This guy made them go up and down, so he's that one.
Maybe it's this one.
Are you Mr. Owl?
Yes.
Talk to dog breath.
Wait a second.
No, they're all jumbled around.
Wait, they're jumbled.
Uh-oh, wait.
So, oh, no, no, just kidding.
Five seats in the north facing west.
Five in the south facing east.
I messed up.
It's backwards, but which one is Andrus?
You can undo them.
They shuffle.
They just shuffle around.
So, it's not him.
It's gotta be this one.
What's happening?
I took too long.
The children.
Oh, there's someone in every window.
What is going on?
What the hell is this ring-ass video?
Oh my gosh, I feel like we're getting cursed for real.
Oh, yeah, I love the party people.
Is that a whale?
No, I don't like the beached whales.
Oh, Ria Jewel, Bakuhatsu.
Oh, is that me?
Oh, no, that looks like a grandpa.
It was like a Warhammer reference.
Don't do it.
Is this death stranding?
I think this is the ring.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Bird.
Now you are ready.
Wait, did I solve it?
Um, there's no way in hell I'm going back in there.
I did.
Oh, I'm a secret genius, I think.
Is there any sneaky ladies around here?
Hey, sneaky.
Oh my god, that's not a sneaky lady.
That's a dead lady.
Oh my god.
Um, uh, my bad.
Go see
Father Allred.
Yeah, Father Allmight.
God, the music in this game is too good.
Like the ambiance mix of music stuff like that, you know.
Oh, spooky.
Are you guys feeling the Halloween spirit?
Uh, do you guys ever feel like...
What is he saying?
She's calling me.
Oh my god, why are you calling...
God, I wish that were me.
Oh my god, scary.
This game is making me go insane.
Seriously.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, a little person crawling away.
Not on my watch.
Please what?
No?
Well, I was...
I'm going mad.
Um, I was saying though, I always feel like more in the spirit of the holiday.
Like the days leading up to the holiday and never on the holiday itself.
Isn't that kind of weird though?
Like I always feel so Halloween-y and then like on Halloween, I'm like, cool.
And then I don't, but I don't feel the same.
Maybe Halloween, I don't know.
Like I feel that very much with Christmas.
Like I feel that so much with Christmas.
Like I feel like I'm like, oh my gosh, it's Christmas time.
Maybe because like I'm going out and I'm like enjoying the Christmas decorations and I'm like going to the stores and they're playing the Christmas music and then on Christmas day, I'm just home.
During your acid trip, you went nuts and ripped through the cultists like you were Doomguy.
Pretty metal.
I'm Gray Fox, I think, probably.
This is, Gray Fox was here.
This is actually a Metal Gear reference.
When it comes time for the real scares, you're just a regular weenie.
No, I'm not.
I've been so brave this whole streak.
I think.
Up the middle.
Celebrations wise, it's the eve, that's the bulk of the celebration.
True, yeah, even that, right?
What do I put in here?
Okay.
Very cool.
Oh, save.
Yippee.
Oh my god.
Guys, is it time?
Filthier Acolyte.
The substance of Gary's influence flows through your veins.
You are corrupted beyond repair.
Your family and friends have forsaken you.
There is no returning from the path you have chosen.
Woo!
Oh my gosh, you're just with your sisters.
Oh my gosh.
Only Gary can save you now.
Give up and fully let him into your heart and mind.
And if you do so, he will make you into a vessel worthy of the unspeakable.
Resist and your soul will be, like, lost forever or something.
Welcome to Tier 3.
Gary loves you.
Oh, is this the mom painting?
Oh gosh.
Just keep going.
Oh, okay.
We're in, like, a real maze now.
Okay.
Oh, that's kind of icky.
All right, let's just keep walking.
Let's just keep exploring.
What is that?
It's a bull.
What did I grab?
Clavis-el?
What does that mean?
What did I touch?
What did I grab?
I don't know.
I'm just taking...
Uh, how'd you do that?
Why am I questioning what's anything in this anymore?
Oh, uh-oh.
It's a loopy room.
Is it gonna happen again?
Yeah.
Try and check the painting multiple times for the good ending.
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
All right.
Take it.
Okay.
What are you guys doing?
Okay, if I just stare at the wall, will you do something else?
Yeah.
Just gonna keep going.
Oh god, there's a child!
I got him.
I killed the child.
Cool.
Anything?
Okay.
Child slain.
So check the painting.
Oh wait, let's go save real quick.
You need to go save.
Yeah, I was about to go.
Oh goodness.
Hold on, guys.
I gotta save first before the painting.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Boss, you killed a child.
Oh no.
He'll appear.
Oh, who's him?
Who's him?
Say his name and he appears.
Gordon Ramsay.
You can move?
Okay.
I'm leaving.
I'm out of here.
Oh, is this who you're talking about?
Rebel.
Oh goodness.
Oh my god, he's fast.
He's really fast.
Can I even save like in this kind of area?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Mr. Meat.
Oh, Mr. Meat.
Mr. Meat!
Where does he come from?
He has a lot of health?
Okay.
We'll just keep chipping away at it.
We'll just keep on chipping, chipping.
Oh my god.
Whatever I can get.
This room seems pretty not bad to get him in.
Oh my god.
Mr. Meat!
Oh, I got greedy.
I got greedy.
We got him?
Oh my god!
You guys, we did it!
We did it!
Let's go!
Now we can get the good end.
What else is over here anyway?
Good job, Minto!
Thank you!
That'll be my first time ever seeing.
Congrats on beating the Unholy Spirit.
Definitely the weirdest of the three hidden bosses.
At least you can now finish what you started.
Yeah.
Thank you!
Thanks, villain.
Thanks for the super chat.
Okay.
God, this area is huge.
I think you just don't go into that hole and waste all the effort.
You put it... Wait, what hole?
Wait, where the heck am I?
Oh, this is... Okay, it's a big old circle.
Does anything happen with this painting too?
Oh,
not this guy again.
Oopsie.
He didn't give me enough time, enough space to get away from him.
Oh, there we go.
Die, baby!
Die, little baby!
I tried to move away from him.
I'm silly.
He's eating on me.
Oh my god.
Can I just avoid this?
Can I just walk around this guy?
I think I can kill him though.
There we go.
Splat, splat, splat, splat, splat, splat, splat, splat, splat, splat, splat.
Let's play red light, green light.
Oh.
I'm scared.
Ah, squid game, yeah.
Oh, this is messed up.
That's so messed up!
Okay, okay.
I thought I could like kill that guy.
I guess not.
Okay, oh I'm all the way back here.
Okay, I'm just gonna avoid this guy.
See ya, baby.
What if I...
Okay, go back to your hidey hole, lady.
Come on.
Green light.
Fine, fine.
Wait, is this thing already coming in?
No.
There's two of them now.
I just...
Uh...
It puts me all the way back here.
Oh gosh, I wonder if I can try fighting one at a time.
I can kind of take it easy with the first part.
Oh, that was close.
Okay,
hopefully they trigger separately.
Oh my gosh, it's gonna come after me!
Oh my gosh, I almost didn't get away.
I almost didn't get away.
Die, die, die!
Okay, we got him.
Little splatty man.
Okay, now we can escape.
Now we can go save.
Easy peasy.
What's gonna happen here?
Oh, it looks the same actually.
Never mind.
Not nearly as interesting as the last painting.
Okay.
All right, we grabbed Clavis R.
Wait a second.
Is it this?
What
about the other room?
You never explored all the way north.
I didn't.
Do I have to go all the way north?
Or do I need a key?
Oh, deliver two into Moloch's hands before opening his navel.
I did that.
Open up, navel.
What do you need?
Like a little key that goes into your tum-tum?
What do you want from me?
Still gotta go north.
Okay, I'm trying to speed run.
I'm trying to speed run here.
Touch stummy.
Touch fluffy tail.
Okay, all right.
These guys in their cages.
Oh, let's just go north.
Let's go.
Oh, I don't know.
What the hell is this?
Oh, it's a mirror.
Oh, don't like that.
Don't like that.
Oh, I just...
Mental monster girl quest enjoyer.
Yeah, of course.
Though, I haven't played the third one.
I'm a fake fan.
But, okay, to be fair, the third one was not out when I played.
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
Hmm, I don't like this part.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, he's really ugly.
Wait, it's confusing the hell out of me.
I don't like this part.
Okay, uh, this part confuses me.
Okay, so he's like right there.
He's like, oh my gosh, where are you?
Wait, where are you?
Where are you?
I can't tell.
You guys.
Oh my gosh.
Part three is the best one.
I know I gotta play it.
I've been saying that for years though.
Guys, I can't do this.
This is like actually the final boss for me.
More tits.
What the hell does that mean?
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so he's like right in front of me.
Oh my gosh, he teleports.
Please don't do that.
Please.
I can't tell where you are at all.
I can't tell where you are.
Oh my god, he's coming.
Ah, wait, oh, okay.
He's right in front of me.
Where isn't he?
Oh my gosh.
I don't understand what the mirror does either.
I guess, I guess, oh, it can't be covered or else I can't see him.
Okay, never mind.
I get it.
It can't be covered or else I can't see him.
If I can't see him, I can't attack him.
Oh my gosh, he's like right on me.
Oh my god, wait.
Uh, uh.
Should I cross the mask?
Wait, what is that?
Oh,
I hate this one.
How do I get the dang mask?
Okay, he's like right there.
So, I should be able to attack him or not.
Why am I not attacking him?
And he teleports.
Oh, this is so hot.
This is, you guys, oh my gosh.
Please, please.
I'm so confused.
He's gonna kill me.
Oh no, I'm good.
I don't get it at all.
What do you mean you get it?
I don't get it.
Please don't kill me, mister.
I don't know which way to go.
Oh, okay, okay.
Please.
Death, death, death.
Die, die, die.
Oh my gosh, I finally did it.
Yippee!
Okay, let's get out of here.
Don't open up.
Just let me leave in peace, please.
I got the thing for the navel.
The navel face.
What is this even called?
It's called the navel.
I was just kidding, but it actually is.
Okay.
I don't even know how close we are to beating the game.
Congrats on beating your personal demon.
I don't need a mirror, you guys.
I'm a ghost.
Very close.
Yippee!
All right, navel time.
Oh.
Go into the belly of the beast.
Diving in too deep.
Master.
Hold on.
Master of spirits, the body of the mother stayeth suspended beneath the crucible of the profane Sabbath.
If thou can't unlock the final secret of the crucible, know ye this.
The cross hath the power to weaken the mother, but only someone who is ablaze with purifying fire can't truly destroy her.
If thou can't understand these words, thou shalt know the true cost of thy faith.
Okay.
Sorority.
Sorority cult is my favorite.
Oh, do you like the spooky face?
Or the happy face?
You are now a tier 4 acolyte.
Oh my gosh.
Congratulations, girlfriend!
You have descended beyond everything that could possibly save you.
Crazy.
Your words are not your own, and your actions are not your own.
You belong, body and spirit, to Gary.
Oh my god.
Your face itches for the warm embrace of the ritual mask.
You long for the blinding pain of the knife.
You truly are Gary's chosen vessel.
Fear not.
Only a little longer and you will experience the second death.
Adios, alma perdita.
Gary loves you.
Partake of the dark.
Oh, what's this way?
Oh, uh, wait.
Huh?
Wait, what if I actually go up?
What if I go into the dark?
Okay.
I partook... wait, is there a way to avoid that?
Okay, let's just go on then.
There's your answer.
Just death, death,
death.
Everywhere we look.
Death, death, death, death, death.
Oh my goodness.
Okay, I think I need to keep going or else the darkness will consume me.
I think I need to go further.
Oh no, no.
The darkness, the darkness.
Okay, oh, oh, oh, the darkness.
The darkness.
Oh gosh, eternal darkness.
Oh, oh, oh gosh, I don't like this.
I think I made it to the bottom.
Oh, okay, good.
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh, now I can go back up through the tunnel.
Okay.
What is, what is there?
What is that sound?
What is, oh my gosh.
Gary, not Gary?
Oh my gosh, it's purple guy.
Purple guy real.
Um, which direction was the correct way?
Uh, do I, I guess I go, oh, I go up?
Literally, oh my gosh, again.
You can't get me with the same thing.
Purple guy.
Oh gosh, William Afton, that's his name.
I'm gonna go around.
Oh my gosh, Matara's stinking twitch, I mean, uh, steam notification spooked me.
Why are there so many birds in here?
Aren't we underground?
I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh golly gosh.
Oh, oh, we're outside.
When did we get out here?
Okay, I'm gonna follow the little lines.
Oh wow, wait, isn't this the thing I undid?
Isn't this the seal that I got rid of?
Different one?
Oh, they all look the same.
Oh my god, oh, that was so close.
They all look the same to me.
Um, I think I'm lost.
Okay, uh, oh, there we go.
Follow the little things to the holy light.
Except it's kind of unholy since this game is not about being, well, it's actually all about being holy.
But sometimes it's a little unholy.
Oh god, oh shoot, oh my god.
No, girl, I don't want to join your sorority today.
Oh.
Oh, I found one.
Oh, oh, okay.
Gotta go back.
To the... oh gosh, I'm lost.
Um, I'm really lost.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot the person.
Oh, father, why didn't you bring a gun?
Con Gary, Con Gary, virtual demon Gary-desu.
Remember, Gary loves you.
Gary, kimi no koto suki.
Okay, we found one girl.
I don't know which direction she was from.
The one direction, maybe.
Oh god, how am I supposed to know which direction I found?
She was left, okay.
But I like went, oh my gosh, I went like everywhere though.
Summer, we're so glad you're finally here.
Thank you.
Oh, oh, the sorority girlies.
We've been waiting all summer.
Oh, oh, I think I found it.
Wait, I found a house.
What does it say?
This requires a demon voice.
My dearest colleague, Jacob.
Thank you for the letter.
I am delighted to hear of the success of your venture in Pennsylvania.
However, it was not enough to persuade me to join your cause.
I have no interest in crumbling ghost towns, nor government experiments, nor the gibbering behemoths that lurk shamefully in the darkness between worlds.
Such matters are not worthy of my expertise.
My methods may be more delicate than yours, but I assure you they were given to me straight from the source.
The Antichrist will step forth very soon.
The second death will consume this world.
This pitiful fleshy sphere will, still in its infancy yet, everlastingly too late to redeem.
When the time comes, I hope we may reunite as cohorts, albeit not as equals.
Nope, always!
Gary!
P.S.
I almost forgot to thank you for the pet.
I will keep it outside my private quarters as a guard against intruders.
Oh my god, Gary!
Where was your pet?
Oh!
Oh my god, Breaking Bad!
It's the squad!
Gary and crew!
Oh, which one was that?
Oh god, is that the pet?
It's kinda weak.
No girl around here.
Dang it, I went the wrong way.
I don't like this part, you guys.
I don't like this part.
It's too long.
It's too long and I don't know where to go.
I've been following these things and they took me to the wrong place.
Oh wait, maybe...
No...
Maybe I was supposed to go there first.
Oh gosh.
They're really close by.
Okay, it is leading me somewhere else.
Oh my god!
Ah!
Okay...
I'm following.
Okay.
Too late, sucker.
Oh gosh.
Golly, golly, golly.
Please.
Oh, we found it!
Oh, oops.
Okay.
Oh, it's gone.
Nice.
How do I get home?
Maybe if I...
Oh my gosh.
Golly.
I don't wanna have to do this part all over again.
Just go south?
Oh yeah, because I went north, right?
I'm going south.
For winter...
I went too far south!
Guys...
Oh shoot.
No, no way, no way.
I found it on accident!
Is she still there?
You think?
Nice.
Now let's go east.
I mean west.
Shoot.
I can't remember.
East, west, west...
Okay.
West.
Just keep heading west.
Probably.
Probably is correct.
I don't know how we found her on accident, but we did.
Oh shoot.
Oh, that's a girl I killed.
Wait, where the hell am I?
Guys, I'm really lost.
I wanna go back north a bit.
Follow the symbols?
Will they lead me home?
Take me home...
Demon symbol...
To the place...
I will...
Purify...
Oh my gosh, we found it!
What does a ghost owl say at the theater?
Do you really want to open this door?
Yes.
Oh, maybe not.
Maybe a bad idea.
I feel a little out of my element here.
A little priest.
How do you make a portal?
Is that like, how many monkeys does it take to change a lightbulb?
Sometimes it waits for someone who has already walked through it.
Oh no.
I'm the one who created the portal.
Oh no, you used me!
Woo, hell party!
Ah, you silly kids.
Alright, I'll leave you alone.
Sometimes...
Oh!
The kids!
Twins that we were looking for!
Are they the portal to hell?
Hi Gary!
Oh gosh...
Competent.
Yeah for real.
Help me!
A mummy, I hear thee.
John, son of man, what dost thou wish?
Kill Gary.
This is too much for me.
I'm so afraid.
Please let me escape this place.
And the girl?
I've done a lot, haven't I?
Come on!
I just want to go home.
If I leadest thou to safety...
Her fate shall be sealed upon thine head.
You're putting this on me!
Come on!
I'm just a guy!
I'll do whatever you want.
Just take me away from here.
He's done enough.
Swear it.
Why is this his fault?
Time to go to jail.
October 31st, 1987.
The profane Sabbath.
Gary!
My name is Gary Miller.
Oh wait, no.
So you're the one behind all this.
In the name of the Lord, I demand to know what the hell is going on here.
Yeah, what the hell is going on here?
Yo, break it bad!
Well, you have come this far.
Yeah, I'm kind of crazy.
I suppose you deserve some answers.
Fine, you get three questions.
Questions.
Oh!
Injection?
I didn't see...
We never saw the needles.
We never saw the needles, so...
Let's ask about Gary.
Yeah, because I turned it off, but I thought it would censor it or something.
I thought it would...
I thought it would censor it, that's all.
That's why.
It did get censored.
Oh, I just didn't notice it.
The boys.
Huh?
What?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
So we were truly like going crazy in the midst of all this.
I'm curious about this one.
Oh it says victim I think.
A response?
Oh, he's fine though.
Huh?
Oh.
Oh no, is this the final battle?
Kneel.
Say decay.
Wait, how do I get the good ending though?
Unlock the thing.
Unlock.
Oh my gosh.
My cross, I forgot about it.
He's like...
Oh gosh, creature.
Oh gosh.
I'm so slow when this happens.
Da -da-da-da.
No!
No, Rain of Spiders!
I can't do this.
Oh shit, I'm gonna lose my cross.
Oh, I didn't lose it.
Amazing.
I can't.
Don't do it again.
Oh gosh.
That was close.
Don't do Rain of Spiders.
What the hell is that?
Oh shoot.
I avoided it somehow.
Rain of Spiders!
Don't do it.
Can you...
Okay.
Oh my god.
He's just gonna keep throwing his little trident.
Oh shoot.
Okay.
Oh, big skelly.
Somehow he always runs into me.
Rain of Spiders.
Oh shoot.
Little baby!
Oh god!
There are so many spiders!
There are so many spiders, you guys.
I couldn't avoid them.
There are so many spiders.
Oh no, no.
He's gonna run into me.
Oh gosh.
Get my thing, get my thing, get my thing!
There are so many...
Father Garcia!
Yeah!
This is what we should've brought.
A fucking shotgun.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Wait, maybe me alone?
Wait, I have to go in by...
Wait, I go in by myself?
Oh my god.
Oh god.
I go in by myself?
OK!
Rain of Spiders.
The Crucible.
Wait, I'm scared of this.
Oh my gosh, I've never seen this before.
Oh god, is this really hard?
March 18th, 1934.
Mariam is ready.
We will perform the ritual according to her instructions tonight.
It's really hard, yeah?
Oh gosh.
It's pretty hard.
It may take a while.
Oh no, I should've just gotten some padding.
It used to be even harder before it was nerfed.
No way!
OK.
March 19th, 1934.
I've already been playing for almost 4 hours.
It's late and I'm tired.
I hope I can do it.
We successfully gave the second death to Mariam.
We have been passing living newborns through the newly made portal as quickly as we can get them.
Another baby!
So far there has been no response from the other side.
March 23rd, 1934.
After several days of sacrifices, we finally got a response.
A tiny hand reached out from the portal.
We took the hand and pulled out a baby boy.
It appears to be a normal human baby, just like you and me.
We named it Gary!
Oh my gosh, I was about to say!
Is this Gary?
Gary came from the portal!
Where the hell are we?
Gary loves you.
Gary is a normal human being, just like you and me.
Oh my gosh, I just realized we're in the house.
That was so loud.
I think?
Or...
Yeah, right?
This is the house, I think.
And this would be the bathroom.
Nevermind.
Wait.
No.
It's a different house, I think.
A ruined version.
No.
Gary loves you.
Gary is a normal human being, just like you and me.
Oh, we're downstairs.
This is the kitchen.
Oh no!
Our coconut's gone!
So the family portrait would be there.
And I guess I got the note in this room.
Okay, let's go upstairs.
Okay.
Well, we can go to the attic.
Gary loves you.
Gary is a normal human being, just like you and me.
Why do I feel like I'm...
I feel like I got the notes in wrong order or something.
Because the first one had a bunch of lore and these are all just the same.
Gary loves you.
Gary is a normal human being, just like you and me.
Is a normal human being, just like you and me.
Gary loves you.
In the day and in the night, Gary would never give you a fright.
It's just Gary, they all say, and then they all go about their day.
It's Gary... Wait.
This is a puzzle, isn't it?
Dang it!
Okay, so we start...
We start here.
I'm really worried if Gary loves me.
How would I know?
It's not?
Really?
Wait, did I not get the other one?
Am I just silly?
The mannequins toppled over.
Gary loves you.
Gary is a normal human being just like you and me.
Come on Gary!
Oh my gosh.
It's Gary-chan.
We got a real water problem here.
What about all the mannequins over here?
Gary loves you.
All the mannequins.
Oh god, it sounds so close.
What?
Okay.
Go to the basement, they said.
If it's not a puzzle, why do they respawn?
Oh wait.
Yeah, they are here.
I'm gonna try the attic instead.
Just to be obnoxious?
Okay.
Let's go to the attic.
The twins room?
It wouldn't let me in.
Well actually, it wouldn't let me in through one door.
So let's try another one.
Like, one of the ways it wouldn't let me in.
See?
It won't let me in.
Let's try the attic instead.
Gary loves you!
Oh, it saved.
Oh goodness.
Who the hell?
Tag.
Who?
With Tiffany?
Oh god.
Oh, Amy.
But Amy wasn't by choice.
Oh my gosh.
You wouldn't say that!
Oh my gosh, Gary looks like the Sink Baby.
From... Oh my god.
Oh god!
From PT.
Sink Baby Gary.
Oh my god.
Shoot.
I thought he was gonna...
I thought he was gonna do that.
I didn't know.
Oh yeah, I guess Tiffany actually was rejected.
Uh oh, my YouTube froze.
My YouTube froze.
Guys, hold on.
Give me one second before I...
Continue this happens every stream now.
I love it.
Yeah baby.
We love when the stream freezes.
There we go.
Okey dokey.
Alright.
Mortis.
I love you.
Oh gosh, how many times am I gonna hear this over and over again?
How many times am I gonna hear this?
Can I get rid of these?
No.
What about the mom?
Oh, he's gonna charge?
Oh god!
Why does he charge sometimes more than once?
The first time it was only the one time.
He's laughing this time.
I didn't hear that before.
Gary hates us, you guys.
Gary hates us.
Oh, he's gonna charge.
Why is it a triple now?
What?
Yeah, I literally walked right into it.
But I don't understand how the first time he only did it once.
He only dashed once the first time.
See?
He only dashes once there.
I'm so confused.
Stop it, Gary.
Gary, stop it.
Gary, you're freaking me out.
Gary, you're making it really... This is too much pepperoni, Gary.
Gary.
Oh my god, he's gonna dash.
Gary!
Gary, got the zoomies.
Zoomies, Gary.
Too much of pepperoni!
Oh shoot.
Oh my god, no way.
Oh no, no, no.
No, this is so rude.
This is the meanest thing I've actually ever seen, ever.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, how did I live?
Oh my god!
Wait, what the hell is that?
There's a chicken on the screen.
Oh my god, what?
There's two of them!
Oh my god.
No.
No way.
Don't dash.
I
think this might be impossible.
Hold on.
I had something I needed to do tonight and...
I didn't expect the stream to go on for this long.
I thought I would be done around this time.
I told them...
I said I was on the final boss and it's more difficult than I expected.
Why can't I go back to Reign of Spiders?
So he stops when he nearly grabs me.
Oh my gosh.
Stay away from me, Gary.
You're stinking fork hands.
This is why your mom didn't love you, because you have little forks for hands.
Malthus and Gary share a health bar.
Oh, thank you.
Okay, that's good to know.
That makes things maybe feel a little bit more doable, I suppose.
Oh my god, he's gonna charge.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Gary.
No, no, I'm gonna die here for real.
Oh my god.
I knew when he dashed.
I thought he would come for me, but I didn't know he would go up instead.
Guys, why did you tell me to get this fucking ending?
This is your fault!
Oh my god, I want to go back to Reign of Spiders.
This fight sucks.
Malthus.
I don't love Gary either.
I feel like I'm gonna be here literally all night.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, I wish there was a way to predict which way he was gonna...
Malthus.
He doesn't give you any hint.
Gary.
I can't believe you guys suggested this when I literally was just like... Oh my gosh.
Guys, I'm not 100% still.
I'm still, you know.
I'm still, you know, in a little bit of pain.
You're just like, we can fix that.
Just play.
Let's just get the true ending of...
Oh my gosh.
The true ending of faith and then you'll forget all about your pain because you'll be in mental anguish.
It's literally what you guys were thinking.
Oh my gosh, he gives no hint where he's going.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my...
I hate Father Garcia.
Why didn't you come in here with me?
Father Garcia.
Father Garcia, you have an actual shotgun.
Why didn't you come in here with me?
At least when the other guy, when Malthus shows... Why is it already dark?
Are you serious right now?
Evil game.
When Malthus shows up, I feel like Father Garcia should also show up with a shotgun.
I'm just saying.
I think I'm gonna die here.
What if I stand by the mom?
Actually, what if I just hide behind her the whole time?
Maybe that's an idea.
Oh shoot.
Go to the mom.
Go to mom.
Mom.
At least for this part I can do that.
I think.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I got stuck.
Mom's stuck.
No way.
Oh my god.
The dang pepperoni.
I ate too much pepperoni.
Holy moly.
I wish I had any holy moly here.
Oy the pepperoni.
Oh my god.
Okay, so he can crawl up to mommy.
My plan is a little flawed.
But it's not terrible I think.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Why are you doing this creepy run at me instead of doing your sprints?
What is happening, Gary?
You're going against the...
You're going against the pattern!
Gary, you're supposed to have a pattern, Gary.
It's when you're close to him?
Okay.
I don't want to be close to him.
In fact, I want to be quite far away.
Oh my gosh.
Gary!
Oh Gary!
No!
Okay, if they share a health bar though...
All I have to do is avoid one of them, I guess.
Oh my gosh.
I'm telling...
Is there like a way to cheese this, you guys?
Real question.
And if you don't tell me, I will go to YouTube.
Oh my god.
If you don't tell me, YouTube couldn't well...
Faith?
I have no faith!
Oh my god.
No cheese?
Really?
I just have to...
do it?
Oh gosh.
Fine.
Why are you on this side now?
What do you mean?
Why are you on this side?
Malfus.
Oh my gosh.
Malfus, no!
Oh my god, he's about to chase me!
I thought he did his little quick scuttle.
Not the...
Oh my god, I'm on fire!
Oh my god!
You can even...
Wait, can I set him on fire?
Is this the cheese?
Is that a... Oh, no.
How many phases is this?
You guys know?
After...
When Morpheus shows up, how much more?
Three phases!
Oh my god!
No way!
Three...
See, that's what I thought he was doing in the previous run...
When I got caught during...
The Morpheus...
Oh my gosh.
Of the stream.
Really?
And this whole fight's RNG.
It's too cruel!
To get the true end for what?
I could just...
I could just YouTube the true end.
Bragging rights?
Oh my gosh.
Maybe I need to stick closer to him.
So he does just do his little tiny scuttle instead of the long charges.
Oh my god, I'm blocked.
It's a pepperoni!
Ah!
Sorry, super chat went too fast.
I couldn't read it.
We were trying to help me out.
Thank you for the...
No, no, thanks for the super chat.
Oh, it's a pepperoni.
Is this a charge or is this a scuttle?
It's a charge!
No.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
What
do you mean useful cheese and she misses it?
Well if you guys stopped chatting for so much, you pushed it away!
You pushed it off the screen!
How can I...
It's not my fault, I missed it!
Because you pushed it off the screen!
Because of the chat!
It's not me!
See you guys, what are you doing?
Oh my gosh, oh my god.
What the hell?
What the hell is this?
Oh my god, he's dancing on the playing field now.
Now you wanna join us, Morbius?
Oh my god, he's gonna charge.
It's charging time.
Oh my god, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I lived.
A little scuttle.
A little scuttle time.
Oh my gosh, please, please, please, please.
Avoid, avoid, avoid at all costs.
Guys, guys, guys, guys.
Phase 3.
Mom?
Oh no.
What is this?
Touhou Reel.
What the hell is that?
Oh my gosh.
No, please, don't come swooping down.
I don't wanna do this again.
I don't wanna go through it again, please.
Oh my god, poison apple.
My god, take this cup from me.
What the hell does that mean?
Oh my god, do I have lives now?
What is happening?
My god, please, god, please.
This abomination's power is too great.
No, and yet, it is not the end.
Oh my god, oh my god, I have...
How many lives do I have?
I don't even know, I'm scared.
Oh my god, the...
The music's kind of awesome though.
Uh oh, am I gonna die in here?
Oh no, poison apple, poison apple.
Poison apple, poison apple.
I can't, I can't bite you.
And poison apple at the same time.
Please, please.
Oh my god.
Touhou!
What the hell are these danmaku?
I can't attack you if you're doing this.
No!
Perhaps some divine intervention at last.
Perhaps some divine intervention at last!
Oh my god.
Yes lord, I feel thou art with me.
I think I'm gonna die, you guys.
I think I'm gonna die.
Oh no, no, no.
OK, we're out.
Let's get closer.
There we go.
Damn it.
Um...
Five hits left?
Oh god.
Please.
I don't know how much more I can do this though.
Thy saving grace transfigures me.
Oh no, no.
No, no, no, no.
No, please, please.
How much life do you have left, lady?
Please...
Oh my god.
Oh shit!
The power to save myself and those I love!
I'm not fast enough for these.
I'm not fast enough to avoid these.
That's how scared I am.
Please die!
Die!
OK, this one I think is the maybe easiest quote-unquote.
I just have to dance around in it, inside it.
But then she throws the poison apples!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I made it, I made it.
Somehow.
No, no more poison apples.
I hate this one, please.
Please, lady.
Please, lady, let me live.
I cannot go on like this forever.
Please, please!
No, no, no, no, no.
The cross...
The spirit is willing but the flesh is weak.
Please!
Guys, guys, I don't know about this, guys.
Please.
What do you mean go to the fire?
No, too late?
Oh, OK.
How often we forget faith with our words.
No, you guys...
What do you mean it was too late?
What the...what?
I'm so confused.
What do you mean wasting my chance?
I have no fucking idea what this is!
What do you mean wasting your chance?
As if I fucking know what I'm doing!
What do you mean?
This is the first fucking time I'm playing this!
You bitch!
What do you mean wasting my chance?
You motherfucker!
Like I'm supposed to know every fucking thing about this game!
OK, when he splits I'll run to the fire.
Thank you.
Oh gosh!
I was right there!
How are you supposed to know to even do that though?
How are you supposed to even know to do that part?
At least they give you multiple lives in that part.
They're not so cruel.
I just feel like I wasted them.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Holy shit!
No!
Get out of the way.
Oh shit!
I didn't notice.
Hold
on, my tears are going down my neck.
It's uncomfortable.
There was a note that told you?
They expect you to remember that?
What was the note?
What?
This is about the human baby.
The most recent note.
The last note.
This is the last one.
Back one more.
This one?
Thank you for my pet.
No, that's the pet.
What?
When you descend the navel.
Oh, this one maybe?
The cross hath the power to weaken the mother, but only someone who is ablaze with purifying fire can truly destroy her.
Oh my god.
Ok, wow, ok.
Ok.
That is such...
Oh shit, he's right there.
That is actual such bullshit.
It's like, by the way, did you read my note?
Did you read my note, VTuber?
By the way, while you're in mid-battle after having gone through three phases, did you remember my note?
Did you remember what I said to you?
Oh my god.
By the way, when you were freaking out because of the little poison skulls that were flying around your face, did you remember to set yourself on fire because it said so in one teeny little sentence?
On a note?
Did you do that?
Did you do that, VTuber?
VTuber?
VTuber, I figured it out.
VTuber, why didn't you remember that singular sentence that you read like 50 minutes ago?
VTuber?
I think you need to pay better attention to the game, VTuber.
VTuber literally laid it out for you.
Is the VTuber even playing this game?
Are we playing the same game, VTuber?
Because you also ran into the fire earlier and it basically explained the whole thing to you.
Oh my god.
Are we safe?
Okay.
I say safe, but you know.
Oh god.
My little bullets.
Oh my gosh.
He's gonna charge!
No!
Please, I might be trapped.
Oh my god, I barely made that.
I don't know which one would be easier to get, to be honest.
Oh my god.
I don't
know exactly.
Oh, nice!
Okay.
Mommy?
There they go.
Okay, mommy time!
Phase 3, let's go!
Alright, how many lives?
This part is so cruel.
It's so cruel.
I love the final boss music though.
It's so awesome.
Oh
my god, I hate the skulls.
Oh gosh, the skulls.
Oh my god.
Lady?
I just walked over there.
Please, I'm really slow.
You'd think he would, like, run, you know?
Have any sort of urgency.
Mr. Priest.
John Priest.
Any sort of urgency.
Yeah, yeah, I like this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, this one's not so bad.
Nice and cozy with mommy!
And some little poisoned apples.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no, no, no.
Oh god.
This part is actually cruel.
This part is so... What the hell is this?
What is this?
Little Don Muckle... No!
No!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Flames and...
Alright, I avoided.
Alright, lady.
I'm taking you down.
He's walking as fast as he can.
Hello?
Oh my god, I forgot about that part.
Dodge!
Yeah, we did it!
The music is so awesome!
Oh gosh, the poisoned apples!
Oh gosh...
It scares me so much.
Oh, this part.
Don't come towards me.
What are you doing?
Fire!
That was so easy.
Don't skip it.
Oh yeah!
Get his ass!
Eat Gary!
Oh my god!
I didn't think she would actually do it.
Nano, thanks for the...
Oh my god, Murphy, thank you!
Nano, thanks for the tech gifted!
So nice.
At least Toho shows you where your hitbox is.
Thanks for the tech gifted!
Oh my gosh, we did it!
I've been so brave, yeah!
Can I rest?
It's time to finish what I started.
Hey Mac, thanks for the tech gifted!
Zile, thanks for the tech gifted!
Her balls!
Oh my god!
Amen!
Oh my god, it's like the ending of an action film.
Oh my god!
All the cops are dead.
I hope our fingerprints aren't at the scene.
Oh my god.
Yes.
How long did that boss fight take me?
Half hour?
8 hours.
Nice.
Ah man, thanks for the locker so far.
Have crowns too.
John!
Oh my god, the Lisa Riz!
I'll never be able to rest.
Oh my gosh, why didn't you want to stay at my house Lisa?
Oh wait, I get to choose?
I think I kind of want to stay with Father Garcia.
I'm sorry Lisa, but he has a gun.
Bros before hoes.
Let's go fight some demons!
Amen to that brother!
Oh my gosh, you know what?
That was so worth it.
That cleansed everything from me.
Oh my gosh!
Guys, am I a gamer?
Oh my gosh, I did like the hardest boss in the game.
That's kind of crazy.
Oh my god, I'm a gamer.
Winto Gaming.
Yippee!
Amen, brother.
Once I got a little bit more used to the mechanics, it was fine.
It was definitely tough at first.
But then it was like, not bad.
In the last run I was just like, oh okay.
This is pretty... not so bad.
Mint will go through hell to see two mentioned games.
Oh Murphy, thank you earlier for the hackadono.
Thank you so much!
The greatest rewards are born.
Oh, finish the unholy trinity.
Ending to a new journey.
The greatest rewards are born of the hardest trials.
Only sweat, tears, and grit with a little faith can get you to the end.
And your reward?
Peace, bragging rights, and an aka.
Thank you, villain.
Wow, Johnny!
Thank you for the...
Wait, what the hell is this?
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted!
Thank you!
And lost in the story, thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
Thanks for the perk!
Congratulations on the true ending.
Thanks, Kyle!
She gave it to us.
Thanks, Dawn!
This thing just popped up on my YouTube.
It says goal.
Make Super Chat more fun with a goal.
What the hell is this?
Set a goal to engage your audience in a new way.
Once you reach your goal, celebrate with your community.
Okay, if I get one Super Chat of $2...
In 15 minutes.
Share how you'll celebrate.
What is... Hold on, you guys have to tell me what this looks like.
What is this?
Do you guys see this?
It's not telling me if we made the goal or not.
Why isn't it telling me if we made the goal or not?
You guys are Super Chatting.
I think it's broken.
We did it!
What a stupid feature.
It literally just popped up as I was looking at the stream.
Best stream ever!
You guys are all just Super Chatting.
Yeah, it feels like a Twitch feature, doesn't it?
It's a not-hype stream.
These are kind of crazy though.
Because if I set another goal...
I can pick a goal of 50 Super Chats.
And I can pick red and higher.
What do you mean and higher?
And then I can set a timer of 15 minutes to 3 hours.
And then I share how... Oh, let's see.
Get inspired with examples.
Here are some ideas for you.
If we reach 10 Super Chats, I'll react to hilarious animal videos.
YouTube, no!
Last time I did that, I got a strike on my channel.
What are you talking about?
If we reach 10 Super Chats, I'll play the next game blindfolded.
No, I won't.
If we reach 10 Super Chats, I'll spill a secret.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you, I feel very inspired.
This is so funny.
We know Zoo Camp scares you, Minto.
It's okay.
No, it's the spy animals.
YouTube is turning more into Twitch every day.
I don't mind some of the Twitch features as long as...
As long as the Twitch culture doesn't show up, I think.
You know, some of them are good, I think.
I think, you know...
But...
I think this one just encourages you to donate.
I usually have to tell you guys to not do that.
Animated emotes.
Yeah, see?
That's great on Twitch.
And the animated emotes.
I know, I haven't ever even commissioned any.
Because I'm like, what's the point?
Minto's secret funds.
Rest in Aura, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh my god, bone removal expert.
I wish they'd fix chat using 18 gigs of RAM instead of adding more features.
So true.
But don't worry guys, I don't plan on going to Twitch.
So...
What was that?
Donate?
Yes, my lord.
No!
Get Aura!
I actually was talking about it with someone recently.
And they were like, you know...
They were like, you know...
If you had to choose, would you go from Twitch or YouTube?
Or which would you pick?
And I was like, no, I think I'm gonna...
I think I'm gonna...
Stay on YouTube.
I think like, if I...
Hold on.
I think if I were...
I think rather... Hold on, let me...
If...
For smaller VTubers, I'm pretty sure Twitch is better to start out on.
I hate the ads on Twitch.
I know!
They're so bad!
And then every other day I see something about another VTuber getting banned for some arbitrary reason.
It's crazy.
And...
But I think Twitch is better for visibility on...
For newer VTubers.
But, you know, I started on YouTube.
Even though...
No one else really that I knew at the time was on YouTube.
I was like the only one.
All my friends were on Twitch.
So it was a little weird.
But...
You know...
I think, obviously, I'm way more...
In a privileged position than most, you know, indie VTubers.
Because...
You know...
I...
Came from heaven.
So...
I have more reason to stay on YouTube than other people, maybe.
I don't think I would've still started on Twitch though.
I don't know, it just doesn't...
Feels different than...
Than...
I don't know.
I just don't understand the Twitch culture.
But I do watch some Twitch streamers.
I also really enjoy having VODs.
I love that so much.
Twitch VODs are just not the same.
I enjoy having VODs so much.
But...
I watch some Twitch streamers.
And then I watch like, you know, some other V...
Like VT...
I say streamers.
I watch one Twitch streamer and then...
But they also simulcast to YouTube.
So it's like, why not even?
Raichi, thank you!
Great gaming, Minto!
You're so brave!
Amen!
Thank you, Raichi!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
And thank you for the...
Akadono...
Offstream...
Yesterday!
I really appreciate it!
I'm glad you enjoyed the karaoke!
Thank you!
Mm-hmm.
I mean the roaches on Twitch.
Yeah, that's...
I...
That's her preference, you know?
Praise be for beating faith, my lord.
I'll start going to church just for you.
This must be the sign!
Only one Twitch streamer?
Sorry!
The streamer is a flesh streamer.
Oh my god.
But I watch a couple VTubers on...
On Twitch.
Whoever is kind of like streaming and stuff.
Should a person switch from...
From Twitch to YouTube?
I don't know.
I always was on YouTube, so I stayed on YouTube.
I think it would be hard to switch...
One way or the other.
I think like...
All your audience won't follow, you know?
Like...
Flesh.
Is it Phasmofleshman also on YouTube now?
Yeah!
That's the streamer!
His name is Insim.
I really...
I fall asleep to his videos all the time.
And he streams in the middle of the day.
So I watch him while I'm like working on stuff too.
Thank you for pushing through the final boss.
You did so good.
Thank you!
Speedpandy!
Sorry for getting dramatic in the middle, you guys.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know why I got so frustrated.
I think it's...
I'm tired.
I think I'm just sleepy.
I'm so sorry for getting dramatic.
I got really dramatic.
I got so frustrated I cried.
But it even wasn't...
I didn't even...
I was only at it for a half hour.
I wasn't even at it for that long.
It took me like 35-40 minutes to...
Because I remember...
Right before the fight, it said...
I was like, oh my gosh, I've almost been streaming for 4 hours.
And then, I beat it in like 30 minutes.
I'm so dramatic.
I'm so sorry.
A long ass half hour.
I know, right?
Gosh.
Yeah, I was tired of all of Gary's shit.
I was tired of taking it from him.
I did everything.
I did everything to get to that guy.
And then, he's just like...
I'm gonna split into two.
And one of them is gonna shoot arrows.
And I'm gonna chase after you sometimes.
And sometimes, I'm gonna creep at you.
And then, the lady...
Oh my gosh.
The fact that the note...
Is the only way to know that you need to set yourself on fire during that part...
And run at her is so...
Oh my gosh.
It was a long stream and a hard boss, but you came through.
Yeah.
Gary does not love you.
Really rubbed it in.
Oh, right.
And then, I'm taking you to get so killed for a bit.
I don't think I ever would've remembered.
Oh, thank you guys for telling me.
I would've never remembered.
I thought this game was awesome.
Good job.
My birthday is on Halloween.
But I don't want to interrupt your re-debut.
Can I get a happy birthday today?
Of course, Senpai!
Oh, I'm sorry.
That I won't...
I will say though, on Halloween...
I'll give a generalized happy birthday...
To all of the Halloween babies.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Senpai.
And happy Halloween.
Thanks for the streams.
Been having a blast being a part of them.
Proud to be a new Wisp.
Nevermore!
Thank you!
Happy to have you here.
Everybody, be nice to the new Wisps, okay?
Be nice.
You guys, you know how difficult it is to not...
Oh my gosh.
To not just be like, screw the debut.
I'm gonna stream with my new form now!
Do you know how difficult it is?
I just have to wait a couple days.
What's today?
Okay, it's almost Tuesday.
Tuesday, Wednesday, and then Thursday!
Oh my gosh.
Huggy night!
Welcome to membership!
Yeah, it's all done.
The new model.
My new form.
But, I'm still waiting on two pretty big things.
I think they'll be done in time.
I finished up something today.
That I was able to work on...
That I was going to work on...
Tuesday.
I was gonna work on it Tuesday, but since I got sick, I was able to work on it during the weekend, so I was able to finish it up.
What if you streamed with just the silhouette of the new model for the last few minutes?
But, like, you can't see anything.
It's just real bad though, because it's not a new outfit.
So, it's not like a new outfit or anything.
Too risky.
Nah, we'll wait.
We'll wait, it's just a couple days.
It could be a trap.
It's not a new outfit, it's not maybe the most exciting, but...
I feel like I've been...
I've looked like this for so many years now.
Well, I guess...
It's been like...
Not years, but like years.
You know what I mean?
Because I was gone, but I came back.
I actually didn't even get to stream this much with Mint 2.0...
Before I left, so...
Honestly, it's been nice to be able to use it.
But...
I did see someone kind of mention something.
That was like...
They commented on one of my posts.
When I was like, oh yeah, my...
Redebut is happening.
And they were like, please don't retire...
Mint 2.0...
Because, you know...
KGRmama worked really hard on it and...
Matara, you know, the rigging was a gift from Matara.
And...
You know...
I talked to KGRmama.
I actually...
Before the announcement and everything, I said...
You know, I let her know that...
I would be getting a new mama.
And she was very okay with it.
I think the thing with KGRmama was that...
And it happened with this model as well.
Sometimes, I think her condition is kind of bad.
And she gets a lot of commissions.
And she was very busy and stuff, so...
It would be hard, I think, to continue...
With...
You know, KGRmama's art is so cute and so great.
It would be hard to continue, I think...
Having...
Being with KGRmama.
But of course, you know, I'm always going to appreciate her.
And...
You know, thank her for birthing me...
In my original form.
She was sick recently too.
Yeah, I know, so...
I don't want to obviously be like...
Please, new outfit!
And then, you know, it wouldn't be fair for her...
For me to kind of push that kind of stuff.
And if I were to say I decided a date that I wanted to debut on...
It wouldn't be fair to you guys to be like...
Okay, I announced it and then I have to push it back.
Or things like that, you know, so...
And that's one reason I made this decision.
And then as for the gift from Matara...
Actually...
For, you know...
Having Kevin do the rigging...
It was mostly because it was like a time thing.
I was totally okay with coming back...
With my original rigging.
And Matara was like, no, no, no, you should be like new and shiny and don't worry about it.
But it was kind of like a...
It was like almost a last minute decision.
Like, we were...
Like, Kevin was able to do it in like a month.
So...
We just needed someone to kind of do it quickly.
And Matara, of course, is totally okay.
She loves the new model.
She...
She is really excited for me.
And so, you know...
She's not at all offended, you know.
That I decided to not use the rigging that she got for me.
Like, she did it because she wanted to.
It wasn't like me being like, oh, I wish I had new rigging.
You know, it was like...
Her...
Yeah, it was like her...
Just kind of being like, oh...
I want you to have this so that, you know, you feel like you are updated.
So...
Yeah.
You know, don't think that...
And even though I won't use this form anymore.
Don't think that I am like...
Throwing away my past.
Don't think I'm like...
Not...
Appreciating, of course, what I was given and the people I worked with.
So...
Have you considered doing Vinny's community game, ChoicerVoicer?
It has Metal Gear, Troll 2, and I think Neil Breen packs.
What the hell is that?
Well, check it out.
Thank you.
Vinny's community game, ChoicerVoicer.
We're not forgetting KGR.
We can grow and still love her work.
And I just know Mataro wants to see you develop your channel further.
Thank you.
Oh, it's okay.
I love the current outfit anyway.
It's the same outfit.
Just a little different.
I saw a cosplayer that was just like...
Here is my cosplay before...
It's outdated.
And honestly, I was just like...
The only thing you have to change is like...
Not a lot.
It's basically the same outfit.
No leotard though.
Instead, there is...
Can we get a goofy smile meant one last time before re-debut?
What do you mean by that?
What is a goofy smile?
Oh, like the wide smile?
5.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the gifted.
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I can't read.
Thank you.
My wide smile.
Hold on, I think actually...
I think there is... Oh wait.
Hold on.
I think...
There is so many things that Kevin allowed me to do.
So many things that I was like...
I feel like...
For 3.0, I kind of really dialed it back with a lot of expressions.
Because I was like, I want to stick to the ones that I use the most.
But this one, he gave me...
Oh, that's kind of freaky.
I'm floating, I'm a floaty girl.
Let's see, what else did he give me?
Hold on, I have a way to make my...
To make my...
Mouth...
Big.
Like, I can even do this.
Oh, wait.
That's not what I meant to do.
But I never do this.
Oh, why am I big?
What happened?
And...
Oh, like this?
Wait, that didn't work.
Nevermind, it didn't work.
I think my keyboard is not right.
Oh, whoops.
Have I ever showed you guys that I can sit?
Hold on.
I can even sit.
I can sit.
I can just like...
Chill here.
And sit.
I can just sit.
I'm a sitting duck.
I'm just chilling.
What else can I do?
I can lean, but I think it's kind of freaky looking.
Goodness.
I think it's kind of freaky looking.
When I do the lean.
Wait, how do I do it?
Oh, here.
God!
Help!
Wait, how do I stop?
Oh my gosh.
I don't think it looks good with me.
So I never...
And then of course I can be a chibi.
Oh my god!
Wait, what if I lean like this?
Oh god!
It's so freaky.
I'm dying.
I'm already dead.
Oh here we go.
Oh my god, it's like an atrocity.
It's so...
It's like a monster.
Oh my gosh.
Oh this one though?
I never even asked for this, but...
This one is always cool.
That he just gave me this.
Thank you Kevin.
Wait, there was a way though.
I can't remember.
Oh...
Sleep?
What's this one?
Oh god!
Oh my god!
Wait!
That's not me you guys!
How do I wake up?
Oh my god!
I
thought there was a way guys, but maybe there wasn't.
Wait.
Oh my god, my mouth.
Oh my god.
Is this what you wanted?
Is this...
Is this what you...
Is this what you wanted?
My mouth is...
Oh my god!
You can see my...
Oh my god, it's disturbing.
Maybe I should have used this for my Halloween costume.
I think though...
It wasn't even this that...
This was not the reason that my mouth was so wide.
It was because I was using Gidi's computer.
I think Gidi enhances her mouth.
Onigiri.
This in the lean scares me so much.
Oh my gosh, wait.
What if I do this while I lean?
Ok, hold on.
Hey guys.
It's me.
Minto.
Hey, you gonna let me in?
You gonna let me...
Oh god!
Wow.
Ok guys, well thank you for faith.
It's midnight for me, so I'm gonna go to sleep.
We got the good end.
We did it.
Did I just hop?
Oh my god.
She's bouncing.
I'm hopping.
I'm bouncing.
Sorry, I can't bounce in my 3.0.
But I have some other cute expressions I think you guys will enjoy.
I hope you guys enjoy the overall look.
I'm much more baby.
It's kind of crazy.
It's kind of crazy how baby I became.
I will become.
If you guys are just like, oh Minto cute now.
You don't even know.
Omg Mint Phantom.
Omg Kuro.
Thanks for 2 months.
It will be a lot of fun.
Thanks for the stream and for showing off.
I love Spooky Mint.
Please do it again.
Hold on.
It's really good with this music.
Happy Halloween.
Sweet dreams.
Thanks for watching.
And I'll be watching.
Good night.
Thank you for the donation.
Thank you.
Even though Gary doesn't love you, your wisps love you.
Thanks for all the donations you guys.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.